recently a contest was launched for
those interested in making math physics
explainer videos it's essentially the
physics version of three blue one browns
contest and brilliant has come on board
to divvy 5000 usd equally among the top
five the details are linked below
professor astricar is the eberly
professor of physics and the director of
the institute for gravitational physics
and geometry at pennsylvania state
university and is the man responsible
for loop quantum cosmology roger penrose
has described ashtakar's approach to
quantum gravity as the most important of
all the attempts at quantizing general
relativity i'm proud to say that this is
ashtakar's podcast premiere in this part
1 we cover what was there prior to the
big bang the myth of singularities
buddha's parable of the poison arrow as
well as the inner versus outer world
some of the physics can be a bit
esoteric especially the technicalities
of loop qg giving a taste as to what
it's like to study the subject if you're
interested my name is kurt jaimungle i'm
a torontonian filmmaker with a
background in mathematical physics
dedicated to the explication of the
variegated terrain of theories of
everything that is primarily from a
physics perspective but as well as
investigating what role consciousness
has to play in the fundamental laws
provided these laws exist at all and are
knowable to us if you'd like to hear
more podcasts like these then do
consider going to patreon.com
kurt jaimungle it's support from the
patrons and the sponsors that allow me
to do this to put out podcasts of this
quality of this length consistently as
this is now what i'm able to do full
time today's sponsor is brilliant
brilliant is a place to learn
mathematics science and engineering in
an interactive form soon i would like to
speak to chiara marletto on information
theory so i decided to take brilliance
course on random variable distributions
and information theory and after taking
that course i could finally see why
entropy is defined the way it is there
are plenty of other different courses
you can even learn group theory which is
what's being referred to when you hear
that the standard model the internal
gauge groups of the standard model are
contingent on u1 cross su 2 cross su 3.
visit brilliance.org toe that is t-o-e
to get 20 off the annual subscription
and i personally i recommend that you
don't stop before four lessons i think
you'll be greatly surprised at the ease
at which you can now comprehend subjects
you previously had a difficult time
grocking alright now part two will be in
a few months so note your questions down
in the comments for me to ask the
professor thank you and enjoy part one
with the great aby ashtakar making his
podcast premiere on the toe channel
professor i'm extremely honored to be
here with you you're one of the
preeminent physicists of our era and i
think i speak on behalf of much of the
audience when i say that we're lucky to
be
alive during the same time that you're
alive and it's an honor man thank you so
much for joining me on toe
it was my pleasure because um
i mean
it's one of the very rare
places
where
people are interested in theory of
everything which includes not just the
physical world but also the inner world
and that has been my passion so it is a
very very good match for me
the inner world you mentioned we're
going to get to that too no both both
the the you know well as well as the the
outer world i mean not just kind
of not just the physics sense of theory
of everything but really theory or
everything
yes everything and that includes the
overlap between those and we gave or you
gave a great analogy prior about the
compatibility condition on a manifold on
a sphere we'll get to that i'll give a
bit of an
overview for the audience as to what
we're going to talk about
roughly in order loop quantum gravity
because that's what you're most famous
for
and loop quantum cosmology the big bang
black holes
the second law so there's
we deal with entropy at some point and
causality perhaps even the arrow of time
the differences between the inner and
the outer world and what you believe are
ingredients to a theory of everything
and perhaps even some of the philosophy
of physics
unfortunately there were myriad
technical issues thus the audio of asta
cars isn't as pristine as it could be
keep listening as it improves with time
how about you give people an
introduction as to how you view
what the outer world is and what the
inner world is perhaps what led you to
that as well that distinction and also
the utility of the inner world which is
generally discarded
yeah so
outer world we i just mean the physical
universe that we sort of inhabit we
study we it can be physics like what
we're talking about you know it can be
planets and stars and
gravitational waves and cosmology and
black holes it can be just a tree
outside my window up here and so that
all those those things and you know they
all seem to have some laws and science
has been incredibly successful in
actually finding many many of these laws
and understanding the why things happen
in the external world that we see
but there are also been kind of old
traditions
which focused
much more on the inner world
and the problem there
was
not i mean
i'm talking about kind of the best
things that i've come across i'm not
talking about everybody so
um so the problem there was basically
um
not that the outer worlds are of the
world and phenomena etcetera etcetera
are not important
but somehow
the central theme
should be
why is there suffering
and
what would lead
to lessening or elimination of suffering
there's a very very beautiful story
of attribute regarding buddha
so the statement is that one day
a young
monk
came
in the
hour where people could go and ask
questions and sat
and
asked him and it's very beautiful
it says he sat down and said he says
i was meditating the other day
and the following thoughts came to me i
should have looked this up before a
conversation because i would probably
not reproduce
right but his name was
well sir i was thinking about this
and
the following thoughts are for today
why is the universe finite
or did it have a beginning
was did it always existed i mean so is
it finite in time or
is it universal finite in space or is it
infinite
these are the questions we asked today
right yeah it's amazing
and then he goes on about eight
questions that's why i should have
looked at the other questions
these were the first two questions and
then he sort of says that well does
would the
exist after the after death
or would that not exist after death or
buddha exists both exist not exist
so it goes on in
first of the outer world and then you
know with more
spiritual questions
keeps quiet
then
his balance is disappointed
so he's waits there
very respectfully for whatever time was
supposed to be appropriate and then
leaves
comes back a week later says
i'm sorry but i
those questions continue to bother me
i'm really troubled and he repeats the
questions again they say yes i think
they want to write questions again it
sounds like me
so buddha doesn't answer again
and
then and
third time he comes and he says
that every time i come i ask this
question she repeats the question he
says
it should be simple for you to say
that you know the answers or you don't
know the answers and if you know the
answers what they are
your silence does not please me that was
the one one phrase he says
and basically
something that if he doesn't get his
answers he will leave the sangha you
know the
community of monks
and buddha implies
he says first of all you didn't
join sangha conditionally
but of course if you want to leave you
can give any time anybody can leave any
time nobody is born here
and secondly the reason i don't answer
those questions
is because they have nothing to do
with the central
problems
that
that this sangha is all about and it has
to do with
sufferings
understanding those questions
and understanding answers to those
questions or exploring them and
understanding them sufficiently will do
nothing to the reduced reduction of your
suffering
and then i think buddha gives an analogy
it says
there is supposing you
they
you you go
and
now
i forget details but you're wounded by
an arrow
and then the doctor comes the doctor
wants to put something to eat some
medicine
so you say
no don't put me in the bed don't put the
medicine first i have to know
where did you get those plants
how long were those plants marinated why
this plant and not some some other plant
has this medicine been used always if it
was not used always why did it start
using now and what changes
but if you do that he says you will die
before you you're cured
he said the same thing is true
with these questions about the external
world
now what i like about this
is not that he belittled the questions
about external world
but he just honestly said that this is
not what he is what is about i mean it's
like if you like is like saying that you
know somebody comes to physics class and
asks questions about
neuroscience or biology or something and
you know i
you don't know the answers to those
questions you are the wrong place
so
i think
so there's a there's a there's really a
statism there is really division between
this external world and the internal
world and it does grow
i mean like
uh france
several centuries it has it has grown
and
i think it's a pity because on the other
hand we are all human beings and we we
see the external world and
we have the internal world we cannot
just deny the internal world
uh
again in the talk talk of this
transformation i mean he said that
philosophers of all time they were
interested in two things one is
the natural world the natural philosophy
it's secondly wisdom the wisdom was
that you live what you believe
and therefore you are a shining role
model of what we believe
and then he goes on to say that today's
scientists are not that
they're no different from a lawyer or a
banker or any anybody else as far as
their old wisdom is concerned or their
own belief
you know
in practicing what they truly believe
and i think there's a lot of truth to
that
and i think that's a pity
that i think it should be
it could be much nicer if in fact one
was in
more people were interested
in both aspects of this world
and so i think this was where was this
this was um
in the early 80s i think
i felt that i always been interested in
the internal world
whatever is maybe because i was born in
india it's not that my family was very
spiritual or traditional something i
don't know but i
read some things you know i also read a
lot of
you know
scientific things many more than the
internal world and things but still
there might have been some atmosphere or
whatever it is i've been interested for
a long time
so in about 80 sometime in 80s i sort of
felt that
you know this really is
i mean the point was that there seems to
be such a
such a chasm between the two things and
when i listen to scientists for example
one thing that i like about science
scientists very much compared to the
people experts in the internal world
is that one doesn't think one has the i
mean if you're not
yes okay of everything in this in the
physics world that everything is going
to be explained
tomorrow
then people don't think that
there is absolute
truth
and that is just around the corner or
that some people know it or some people
have already arrived is absolutely true
i mean with my great
i mean
admiration is the wrong word but yes
oh for einstein and so on i have no
hesitation saying that einstein was just
wrong about many things
i mean he was wrong about the
cosmological constant and he in fact you
know he was wrong about the big bang
first of all when he heard about
treatment solution he didn't believe in
it
finally when he understood that the
marriage was right he told
the method again
that
in one of the solute conferences
actually that
the idea of the big bang is completely
repulsive to him
so it's completely different you know
and then i you know same thing about
cosmology constant there's a whole idea
about you know
and then actually
i told you about
the metra going and
correcting i'm
just
telling the pope to you know behave
you also told einstein explicitly
long time ago right i mean
that
why do you throw away because why do you
say the cosmological constant cannot be
there
it's not an aesthetic question see the
aesthetics again i mean you and i it's
not right it's not an aesthetic question
it's an observational question it's
either there it's not there and we see
today that
was coming
anyway
so but then i said we had no problem in
saying that einstein was wrong or you
know more was wrong and very yesterday
but that is not accepted in the in the
internal world and you couldn't go and
you know in a conference and say or you
know
that was wrong
so
i think that this idea that there is
absolute thing and you arrive there and
then that is static
that i find not very pleasant and not
not very
scientific or not not very useful
attitude
not you know it's just a it's a attitude
which is self-limiting
well scientists don't have that attitude
so that it's good about it
but there is this problem you know you
go and talk to these people and they
they want to dismiss science at once and
you talk to scientists and they want to
dismiss
anything
just close your eyes
there's a reality there huge reality
that you are dealing with all the time
and somehow that it is not interesting
it's a this is a
and so i i
sometime in 80s i thought that is really
important that you know that
what is the nature of reality and each
of them
somehow
think that well i can just extending
keep extending and then
it will cover everything and internal
work people think they are already
extended and
like you know science keeps progressing
and progressing and progressing and you
know just
just reach there
we don't know right and it might take
infinite time to even describe the
external world we don't know that it's
going to happen in the finite amount of
time we make continuous progress and
wait and there's no question it's deeply
valuable it's beautiful when you
discover something new as there's no
question about it
but then
so
so therefore i came up with this idea
that maybe you know reality is perhaps
if you at all want to model it
however incomplete that may be maybe the
best model by a manifold picture as i
was mentioning to you the other day it
can be more complicated manifold but the
simplest example would be just a
two-dimensional sphere the surface of a
ball
and we know from the globe you know from
the
earth so looking at the maps and such
thing and then the globe that if you try
to project it down
on a plane
then you have to do the projective map
you can take this north pole and then
project each point of the globe
draw a straight line and then we get a
get a faithful picture
of everything but the north pole on a
pit it's a very distorted picture it's
not it's a conformal
diagram so it's another it doesn't some
areas look much bigger than they really
are and so so but you get that picture
but you cannot cover the whole
the whole sphere with a single chart
single coordinate system single x and y
things
and so i felt that maybe that is that is
true with reality that there is the
internal world and there is an external
world
and the best case may be that you know
you can try to cover more and more of
the internal world more and more of the
external world and they will give you
some some charts to say
and then the deep question is going to
be about the overlap functions because
that is where the
the transitions
the yeah the the key thing about
manifold lies right i mean is this the
compatibility of the two charts
compatibility coordinate system that
they overlap you can have a north pole
chart you can have a south pole chart
and around the equator there are
compatibility conditions that should be
satisfied in other words the same
phenomena can be looked at in two
different ways and they should be
compatible with each other
and i think that is what
is likely to happen that as time goes on
and in particular for example
i was very surprised i just heard about
it on the
less than 10 years ago maybe six years
ago or something like that
about this all these advances in
neuroscience where they can they have
been able to take the image of the brain
very much but in particular
these advances had to do with
some experiments with
which people i think his name is
brewer and you used to be in yale but
now he has his own company somewhere
else um
he
there's a paper in proceedings of
national academy about this in which
they actually
took some
monks who were what are
non-monks i mean
who were trained
in meditation
but
solid long training in meditation not
not beginning months
and then he
uh
had them
kind of their brain scans while they
were actually began meditation and he
purposely tried different kinds of
meditation you know this compassion
meditation there is a
sensational meditations feeling
sensations and
loving meditation and they tried all
those various techniques
and they found that what happens is in
this on all these practices
is that
the
certain circuit in our brain which is
called dna or default default mode
network
it's a it's a rather big circuit
that is the circuit that
is most active when we are
in normal state
and the way that we hold the world
normally
is through an internal dialogue we are
not necessarily conscious of it but
there's continuous dialogue continuous
continuous continuous
and it has to do with basically it's
very centered around the idea of what i
me
mind
self i'm very sick
and what happens in these meditative
practices is that those circuits quieten
down enormously
and
and there are other circuits which are
more
related with functional functional mode
circuits they don't slow down
now for most people even though they are
all of them are very practice practiced
monks
once the meditation they came out of
meditation
then the neurons started firing and
those that default more than books again
but there were a few exceptions and
these by the way are the ones who are
which are i first came across this in
the
book by
robert wright
uh called why buddhism is true
it's an interesting book i mean he was
evolutionary he was a science writer for
evolution psychology was a speciality so
it is tilted quite a bit towards
evolution psychology and i don't
i don't agree with some of the things
that i said there but it's a very good
book
um and then
he reported this and then i looked up
the you know national academy of
sciences journal and
it got a follow-up reading up here
that there were a few people
who
were in that state even after they came
out of meditation they always messed it
and it seems to me and from the other
things also that we've got some other
time about that several reasons why i
believe that this is a state of what
used to be called enlightenment
so it's not a state in which university
well how you have to go out in the
himalayas in the top
cave or anything like that
it's really a statement and almost all
of them are of course very
deeply practicing meditators and such
things but
it may not be necessary i mean from what
i hear what i've read about some of the
people i respect and is that it it can
also happen
spontaneously i mean
with some effort but now you don't
necessarily have to have
10 years of meditation or something like
that in order to do this so there are
some mental states so that's there is a
possibility of actually having this
overlap functions
namely science would say that always
somehow they were able to switch off
this circuit
and that gave them
when that happens the sense of self
disappears and when sense of self
disappears then there is a
very very different perception i mean
this is
uh
so you know
people that that take silos for example
i mean there are there are there is a
very active
group in johns hopkins who does research
on that
um
and again very respect extremely
respected people and a very solid
researchers and doctors
um
they
the experiences of those those those
drugs is really exactly that definitely
switching off this
circuit and
um
i think somebody said right and
what's i think said
with this surveillance like that when
you get the message hang up the
telephone which is to say
when you realize that that's the states
exist you know don't don't keep taking
this more and more i mean
that's enough to say yeah
so i think that there is enough of
work going on and i'm not saying that
this is therefore going to be solid next
five years ten years my lifetime or
something of that sort
but i think it is possible to reach
those states i mean i i really know some
people
whose brains can show that and their
writings
show
whatever they have told me and i
practiced um
i'm very hard-nosed i i don't want to
take any
advice or i'm also not inclined towards
things like devotion bhakti and not
religious person
but you know
whatever makes complete sense to me i
try to adopt it and this is one of the
one of the principles that they say
right and that
if you want to move towards quote
unquote wisdom you should live by what
you
what you understand what you believe
it's not easy
it's not easy at all but i think it is
not impossible
because we could talk about the inner
and the outer world for hours we decided
to save that for part two and to
continue on with physics ensure that you
note your questions for ashtakar down
either in the comments or somewhere else
for part two which will occur later this
year what is loop quantum gravity and
how did you arrive at that approach
right so loop on gravity is a
is an approach to unifying general
relativity with quantum physics
and this is a long
standing open problem at one stage it
was considered
to be the biggest challenge in
theoretical physics and in some circles
it is still considered to be the biggest
challenge
although
uh because of recent observations both
in
the cosmic microwave background and
gravitational waves
uh
other frontiers have also opened up
which are considered to be equally
interesting
so
i started with with the started out in
general relativity
and from the point of view of
generativity then
the question is really how do we unify
principles of general relativity with
those of quantum physics
and there is a real problem right in the
beginning because
there is a really
attention
i mean general relativity at the
conceptual level is a classical theory
so
in that you've got complete productivity
it's a very geometrical theory it's
sharp and precise
quantum mechanics on the other hand is
by inherently a probabilistic theory
we don't have certainty but we only have
probability amplitudes for various
things to happen
and the techniques that one uses are
also very very different techniques
in quantum theory in conduct theory
things like algebraic methods you know
hilbert spaces linear operators
and conservative principles they play a
major role
but this sort of interesting thing is
that each theory
to begin with
has a claim on all of
physics
in other words general religion would
say not only is it a theory of gravity
but it's also a theory of space-time
structure
and of course all
interactions take place in space-time
and therefore
general relativity sort of tells you how
to formulate the theories of other
interactions
that you know there is a
so metric tensor field behind it which
is also serves as a gravitational
potential but determines space-time
geometry determines causality so it
tells you that equations should be
differential equations they should be
hyperbolic
and so that you have got productivity
and things propagate within the light
corner of any point causality and so on
so forth and everything is described by
smooth tensor films for example
electromagnetic fields gravitational
fields any other field
whereas kind of quantum physics to begin
with is very different in quantum
physics
it also makes a claim on everything that
all systems are quantum mechanical and
they should be described therefore
in probabilistic terms you should have
quantum states or wave functions which
only tell you about
potentialities
and only when measurements are done then
this portion of potential ideas are
turned into actualities
and but on the other hand it says that
the all of physics should be described
in these particular terms
so the one hand whether the geometry
tensor fields smooth metric um litecoin
propagation etc and on the other hand
we've got this quantum physics and so
this attention
and so my interest was like when i
started out this was considered to be
the biggest open issue in theoretical
physics and my interest then was how do
we address this problem how do you unify
the principles of both those things
i came from general naturality side so
for me it was really important
that
there be no what people call background
structures so let me explain what this
means
so in quantum mechanics and even chrono
field theory like for example when you
do quantum mechanical dynamics and so on
we actually have a background structures
which are
um
which is really the space time metric
special metric is given it's the stage
on which various things happen
it's it's indifferent to the happenings
it is fixed nothing nothing changes
um whereas in general relativity there
are no actors there is a drama of
evolution if you like space and time is
not a spectator it's also an actor it's
also a physical entity you can act upon
it and it acts back
you know einstein's equations basically
tell space time how to bend and once the
bent you have got bent space time that
space time tells
matter how to move
and so there is a tension here because
on the one hand in general relativity
there are no background structures there
is nothing which is sitting there which
is there's no stage there's no arena
everything is really
acting with each other
uh the only
they're respected as i would like to say
in this cosmic drama
uh so but gonna feel theory for its very
formulation really
assumes that there is space time for
example the schrodinger equation in
which time revolution but even kind of
field theory uh you know you talk about
causal propagation you say that if there
are
two fields of two so-called space-like
separated points so that there's no
positive signal passes from one to
another then those fields commute so
these are fundamental computation
relations in the theory
and we don't have such a thing because
we got a dynamical metric you know so so
there's not no fixed structure like that
and therefore
there is there is a there's a tension
and coming from general relativity side
i felt that it was more important
that
this background independence the fact
that there are no spectators
in this cosmic evolution
is something that should be put to
forefront and when i started out all
approaches coming from particle physics
or quantum field theory side
to quantum gravity were really based on
this idea that there is a fixed min
kasky metric
and then when you take the gravitational
field itself for example
so that is represented for example by
curved metric g
so what you do is you take of
introduced by hand flat
mintaski met or called milkowski metric
and you take the difference g minus the
flat metric let's call it g naught
and then that is considered to be the
gravitational field
and that was denoted by h
and it was just the perturbation theory
in powers of h so the approaches were
completely perpetuating and what i
wanted to do
was very much
approach which is background independent
and which was non-participating which
was so these were the main ingredients
that i was focusing on
so h just to be clear h is how much the
metric differs from the flat case you're
right so h is how much the metric
differs from the flat gates but the flat
metric is something that you put by hand
so there's a there's a gauge freedom
there as one says it is not something
that is physically determined and the
idea is that only when you sum over all
the terms
then you will find that there is no
dependence on this flat metric
but there are questions about whether
you can actually sum
and that some converges in a
mathematical sense and so on so forth
there are good partial answers to that
in classical theory but you know in in
quantum physics
nothing converges there are infinities
and so the problem is really open even
in classical theory really it's
difficult to get if you start out with
minkowski space which is a flat space
you know it's like
if you look at a two-dimensional plane
or three-dimensional ingredient space
that you're familiar with we're adding
one dimension which is time dimension
and it's all completely flat so the
metric there is basically minus the time
difference squared plus the space
difference square that is a metric that
that is
and so
um
the so this is given to you once and for
all
and then the statement is
the h field for example is supposed to
propagate on the light cones of this g
naught metric that you are given to
given once and for all but another
energy not metric is just a
you know some so something put my hands
and so therefore to give fundamental
uh
meaning to this uh light cones doesn't
it's not appropriate and i think by now
people particle physics even community
sort of appreciates that that that was
not completely appropriate and then when
you take with this flat space-time
metric you know if you want to talk
about black holes and so on locally you
can try to sum up the perturbation
theory and get it locally of that black
volumetric but globally this black holes
are very global concepts
this is not possible
so this was basically the idea
and then the question is how to go about
doing this and so that there had been
you know since the 1950s uh attempts at
formulating general relativity in such
in a suitable way so that you can go
over to quantum mechanics quantum
physics called gravity in a
non-perturbative way without splitting
this so there were side-by-side attempts
the particle physics attempt
were sort of very much started with
feynman but then you know taken over by
many other people particularly
and so on and then on the on the
non-perturbative side we had dirac
and then peter bergmann and his
collaborator his old school and so on
they had developed a certain
approach which is called hamiltonian
methods or canonical con gravity as they
call it canonical you can formulate any
field theory in that particular language
and that the advantage there was that
one did not need to introduce a
fictitious flat background metric
but then the mathematics of that theory
and which was then developed also by
john wheeler and his collaborators
but the mathematics of that theory had
remained completely formal
um and in other words there are
infinities because the system has
infinite number of degrees of freedom
it's a field theory in every field
you an electromagnetic field light that
has infinite local degrees of freedom
and then in in
many theories we know perturbatively
how to handle it through the
normalization but general relativity
turned out to be not renormalizable but
not particularly finite
and so the question was well how do you
then you know what do you do what do you
proceed how are you
and so this was this was not a problem
for dirac bergmann wheeler etc and
therefore they actually tried to go
in that direction to address more basic
questions particularly wheeler about you
know what happens at the big bang and
perhaps we can answer such questions
where
non-perturbative methods are essential
because near the big bang the curvature
is very very large so try to do an
expansion in small curvature quantities
is kind of a very bad method if you like
the instituted method
so this was there but except that
everything was very formal people were
writing down these equations which were
formally written down the famous v ray
david equation is a formal equation
which is written down in the
70s or 60s actually
and but even today it is a formal
equation in other words we do not have
precise mathematical meaning
to that equation and so i want you to go
beyond that
and then
i had three ingredients that came all
together
the first was
um
that there was a formulation of other
interactions of physics you know the
weak and the electromagnetic
interactions
and in those
interactions
the interactions of
popular people who say forces are
propagated by what people call vector
potentials
or in geometry you might call them
connections
it's a vector potential which couples
locally to currents for example in
electromagnetic theory if you want a
local coupling when one have verb
introduces vector potential
whereas in general relativity we only
had
we have a metric i mean there's a
connection which it defines but that's
not at forefront we have the metric and
the metric defines the light course it
defines
what you mean you use meaning to
hyperbolicity differential equations and
so on and so forth
and so famously for example weinberg had
pointed out in his
classic book on general relativity that
this
this insistence on metric has driven a
wedge between particle physics and
gravity
and then i thought that maybe we can
actually remove this wedge
the second ingredient that came at that
time was really coming from
uh
various ideas that people like roger
penrose and ted newman and so on are
introduced coming from twister theory
and in twister theory and so on there is
a certain sector of the theory which is
exactly integrable
and that
i mean in general relativity the basic
idea is a metric
but the invariantly defined things that
defines a strong gravitational field or
big gravitational field is the so-called
curvature which is determined by the
metric
if and this curvature if you like in
maxwell theory is like the maxwell
tensor f nu whose components are
electric and magnetic fields
so where i got similar tensor in general
relativity is called the curvature
tensor
and that curvature tensor or sometimes
called riemann tensor is obtained
by commuting
two derivative operators that are
defined by the matrix
and so
there was this idea
that maybe what we should do is to take
the connection as a fundamental quantity
and this idea somehow somehow
was suggested to me i was a postdoc with
roger penrose and just during that year
that i i was there for two years and
just during that period
raja invented what is called as
nonlinear graviton
which is called a what sorry it's called
non-linear graviton a non-linear
graviton okay one linear graviton it's a
twister construction
it's a rich construction it has
it brings together theory of
differential equations and algebraic
geometry the two things that were
completely separate all along are
brought together
and what roger showed was that
if you look at
a certain simplified version of
einstein's equations
namely the following
what you do is you have got this
curvature tensor but you can break up
the curvature tension into two parts
and they are called self dual part and
antiseptal path and each of them if you
like in maxwell theory also we can take
the maxwell tensor and divide into two
parts called self-dual and anti-septual
and each of them defines a helicity of
the photon so these are eigen states of
the helicity operator a photon is a spin
one particle and it has a rest zero
and therefore its angular is angular
momentum the spin vector is pointed
along its four momentum
and then the it's either along the four
momentum or anti line to the four
momentum so therefore you've got these
two helicities
and in that case the the total spin is
one so it's either plus one or minus one
so self-double solutions would have
helicity plus one and anti-serial
solutions were a helicity minus one
so similarly we can do this
ex er
decomposition
in the case of
gravitational field and you can have
self-dual and intercept dual
solutions of einstein's equations these
however are complex solutions of
einstein's equations
and now in quantum mechanics it doesn't
matter because the wave functions are
complex
but in classical physics we want real
things
now for the maxwell case it does not
matter also because you can take two of
two complex things the complex
conjugates of each other so you can just
add them and you'll get the real maximum
field and that is a real maximum field
but general relativity is a non-linear
theory so you cannot just add the cell
dual curvature and intercept the
curvature to get some metric whose
curvature will be the sum of the two
uh the real part so you cannot get the
real metric by adding because the theory
is non-linear you cannot just superpose
the subdual
solution interceptor solution to get a
real solution
but nonetheless the fact that
sevdos this the mathematical structure
of serve those solutions is extremely
simple this is what roger pointed out
that you can obtain quote unquote the
most general solution of einstein's
equation which is self-doubt
this is you know it's a radical
breakthrough in the way that because
equations are so complicated and but we
can obtain the general solution
einstein's equation using this method
said newman in pittsburgh had another
parallel construction and it turned out
that the two are quite compatible with
each other they are exactly one can go
back and forth between each other
so i knew that there is this exactly
integrable sector of general activity
but
again i felt that well that is still
talking about complex general relativity
and how do we construct a theory whose
limit then would give you classical
usual real general relativity with you
know cosmology black holes and so on so
forth
and so that was my interest my interest
was well on the one hand
this derivative operators are
connections they look like good objects
to do things
but
penrose and newman and other and
privansky there were three people three
slightly different approaches but they
turned out to be more or less equivalent
they suggested that well we should be
looking at self dual things
so therefore what i did was to say that
maybe what we should do is take real
general relativity
but formulate it in terms of this
self dual variables as they're called in
other words
you've got a derivative operator which
acts on
spinners so spinners are
fundamental objects that describe for
example the electron the neutrinos
the quarks in the standard model the
fundamental fermions are all fermi
fundamental
particles of massive particles they are
all fermions
and this in presence of gravitational
field
the equations they satisfy
involves a certain derivative operator
because they are differential equations
but
these fundamental particles
the
uh the the basic level
really are left-handed fermions
right-handed formulas so therefore there
there's only there is a helicity
associated with them and so if you take
the fundamental particles of the
standard model in a gravitational field
then they are propagated by
so-called self-dual part or anticipated
part of the of the curvature can you
give some clarification as to what it
means to be self-dual and then what it
means to be anti-self duo
right
so very good
so
if i look at
let's begin with with the
electromagnetic field
so we've got electric and magnetic
fields and one of the beautiful things
about spatial relativity is that they
can actually be combined in a covariant
manner so that you've got a maxwell
field tensor
so it's a tensor
whose if you like space-time component
is electric field and space-based
component is a magnetic field
so electric and magnetic fields are
combined together already in special
relativity you shouldn't think of them
as separately
if you have an observer
that observer with this full velocity
can decompose this tensor into electric
and magnetic field another observer
would decompose it in different ways so
what you have is really this
this uh
this field if you like
and so uh what we have is a tensor field
which is called f it has two space time
indices so let's call it f mean u
and if you have got a tensor then one
can take its
mathematically you can take what is
called horizontal so you got a two two
dimensional anti-symmetric cancer
and you can
contract it with an epsilon
mu nu alpha beta so this is a total
anti-symmetric tensor
and
what your object is or what you obtain
is again
object with two what you obtain is the
object with two anti-symmetric tensors
or anti-semitic indices so you get an
object the same so it's a similar
structure and so
if you take this epsilon and operate it
on a on a maxwell field you get another
maxwell field if like and that is called
the dual of the first one it's dual
because you are preheated by epsilon
so what does it mean in terms of
electric and magnetic fields well
basically e goes to b and b goes to
minus e
so you you you just do this rotation and
that is what's duality now several dual
is the one
in which
the field is its own dual
but if you look at this duality
operation
in the
uh in the space time signature in that
in the real world which is time is
always safe it's a minus and space is
plus or vice versa
we usually use time as minus so the the
distances are always minus the time
interval squared plus the space interval
squared
so in that signature
this operator duality operator
is actually if you take a square you get
minus 1.
so it means that if you have a self-dual
object
something which is equal to itself
if i again operate it by this
equal to the hearts of itself
hodge to all right exactly then you'll
get minus one
so therefore the self-double objects you
know if you do it twice you get minus
one so therefore the eigenvalues are
plus or minus i
and so if it is plus i it is called self
dual and if it is minus sign it is
called antiseptic
so in terms of electric and magnetic
field and given observer you can say
that e plus id that complex field would
be self dual and e minus ib would be
antiseptic
now coming to gravity gravity is very
similar the curvature tensor is like the
maxwell tensor is the metric that means
that i'm so sorry one more time i'm so
sorry professor i i just want to always
yes it's okay yep every time you have a
question great great okay only because i
want to make this physically clear so
just one note hodge
i may keep this or or may not but a
hodge duel so if people know what a form
is
let's say you have a a manifold that's
four dimensions and you have a form
that's two dimensions then you can
take there's a way of taking a two form
and then identifying it with another two
form well the formula is just there's
the following that you need this
a tensor field because you're talking
tell me how many how technical i can be
so yeah yeah yeah you can get technical
and i need i i need a for form or
actually i need a
tensorflow which is two down to
covariance decision to contravariant
indices and then this contravariant
indices can contract
with the with the form that you give me
and therefore again i obtain
over in two form so i need an object
like that
so
so what you need is technically called
conformal metric a metric up to a
multiplicative factor then you can
actually raise the indices of the fourth
form that you got on the manifold if the
manifold is orientable say and then you
can raise the indices and then you will
get um
uh of
object which has two down states indices
if you like covariant indices and two
upstairs or contravariant indices and
then when you when you i got maybe i
should i don't know so that it doesn't
come true
and then the statement is that i can
contract the upstairs industries with
the downstairs and this is for the form
and get again a form which is downstairs
and this is up here but in the lorenzen
signature which is minus plus plus plus
which is casca signature the square of
the hot dual is minus one
in the remaining signature it is plus
two that's an artifact of the raising so
as soon as you try to raise it you just
get a minus okay and if you had a three
form you could identify that with the
one form you just think of whatever is
the total dimension of the manifold
your n form becomes the dimension of the
manifold minus n that's to say your
hodge duel of your n form okay okay
exactly so that's some way of
identifying different forms now people
are like well what the heck is a form
well there are different ways of
thinking about a form a form can also be
identified with a
with a particle as well but the point of
this is
what i want to know is what does it mean
physically when you say that a theory is
dual or self dual so for example we
could identify
up and down with being a left-handed or
a right-handed particle like okay so
that's there's some correspondence
between the math and then the physics so
what's the correspondence here between
the math of being self-dual and then the
physics like what's concretely happening
when one says this theory is self-double
or not like is does that correspond to a
particle does that correspond to a type
of theory
yeah so in quantum mechanics that chorus
does corresponds to a particle with a
given helicity it is a photon
that
because it is a zero response particle
the photon actually has a spin which is
aligned to its four momentum not not the
energy momentum like four momentum
and then it's either pointing along the
four momentum or
anti
and if it is pointing towards the fourth
momentum
then it is it is uh elicited plus one
the other one is helicity minus one now
when it comes to mathematical
representation of these states of the
photon
then the ones which are which are
pointing in one direction one
electricity they correspond to maxwell
fields which are cell dual
and they're complex because wave
functions are complex there's no problem
and if it is
other helicity then they are called then
that corresponds to the interceptor so
and in maxwell theory is nice because
you can just add the two and get a real
solution that's very good
and the idea that roger had was that and
you can do the same thing with
linearized gravity in other words this
perturbative gravity that i've told you
about which is in which you've got flat
space and then you've got a weak
gravitational field and you can take the
curvature tensor so the curvature tensor
and gravity has four indices and it is
anti-symmetric and first two and
anti-symmetric in the last two it's not
like the
the absolute form because it is not
totally anti-symmetric it's just
anti-symmetric in the first two and it
is between the last two and then some
other algebraic conditions appear and
that's called the remains
and what you can do again is take this
epsilon the
take the hash dual on either of the two
it doesn't matter you can take large
dual either or the last the last two or
the first two it doesn't matter and then
again you will get a tensor which will
have four indices which will be
anti-symmetric in these two and
anticipated in the other two and then
those indices are going to be um
and
again the the the square of the hodge
duality operator is minus one and
therefore
you get
the eigen functions are going to be
complex
and if you look at linearized gravity
and then you can talk about gravitons
the usual way that people talk about
gravitons are all perturbative terms so
that really refers to linear gravity
theory
and in linearized gravity then the
statement is that you can do exactly
what we said in the maxwell theory again
the only difference is that now
the spin is two rather than one for the
graviton linearizer gravity and then
again it is zero response particle so
the spin is either aligned or
anti-aligned and if it is aligned then
it
is it's self-dual and if it's
anti-aligned it is uh it is anti-semitic
can we talk about the helicity when the
particle is not massless
the helicity is usually
is considered it is a social massless
particle okay it's really replaced with
notion of spin because the direction is
already known
whereas normally you know you can have a
if you have a massive
uh vector boson then it would have
uh spin i mean it's not um so it's not
pointing along the so what you know is
that the spin is pointing always along
is perpendicular to the whole velocity
and so so but but the if the fourth
velocity is null
then it's perpendicular itself so it can
spin can point along itself
so there's one other way of
understanding that with a mass
massive particle if it's moving in a
certain direction and it's spinning you
can boost yourself you can move so that
the particle's moving over here but the
but it would still be spinning here so
now it's moving it's spinning in the
opposite direction that it was whereas
before it was aligned so then the
helicity is not defined the pin will
transform like a super vector and that's
so it will so if the four momentum will
transform under lawrence transformations
and similarly the spin vector will
transform but spin vector will transform
like so called pseudo vector whereas
in other words if you change x y z t
then the four momentum will go to minus
its components of the reverse whereas
for the spin vector the components will
remain the same it is like in
ordinary quantum mechanics not relative
okay so as i said this long long
explanations about
kind of gravity so i just want to say
where we went so basically you asked me
about uh how do i start with this kind
of gravity to point gravity and so on
and so
first thing was background independence
and non-productive methods
the second thing was then well but how
do you go about doing it because
everything people had done jirach and
arnovate as a business and
wheeler and debate and so on was very
formal
and so how do you remove that formal
things the second point was well we've
got this
all other interactions are really
governed by this vector potentials or
the derivative operator connection is
one calls it in different geometry
whereas
in gravity it is actually the
um
is a metric that is that that is that is
what is used
and so one one wanted to have more
uniform way of dealing with all
interactions and then the third thing
that came was this idea that maybe what
we should do is not use
so to say
the brute force derivative operator that
the metric gives you
but only part of that derivative
operator
which knows of how to operate on
left-handed
spinners which are the fundamental
particles in our standard model
fundamental formula
so these are the ones which are helicity
so
so so we just look at those ones
and then the statement was that means
that well we should not get rid of the
food metric is not a fundamental object
but even the derivative operator defines
all of it is not fundamental operator
object only a
fraction of it which is extracted out
which is said dual or undeserved or it
doesn't matter is your conventions but
supposing self dual you extract it out
then that is going to be
how what we should be able to do
that should be the fundamental object
and then we should formulate the theory
thinking that that is a fundamental
object and then go ahead
and then the nice thing was that if you
did this
then one could write down
a phase space of the theory which is
exactly like in young wheels theory
which which govern other interactions
the weak electromagnet the the electro
weak and the strong interactions so the
weak electric and
weak electromagnetic and strong
interactions they're all governed by
so-called young
theory in which there is a
uh connection here also now there is a
connection it just happens to be subtle
it's a gravitational connection which
knows how fundamental particles move
in presence of
gravitational field the electromagnetic
connection tells you how electron
charged particles move
in the presence of um
electromagnetic field external
electromagnetic field
the young the strong interaction
vector potential a which is
that tells you
how quarks move in presence of um
uh in presence of a uh
glow on field
this connection is a blue one in that
case
and now the statement was that
you now take this fundamental
constituents of matter which are
fermions which are which have precise
helicity uh this is before the symmetry
breaking so they have precise helicity
so
they're massless at that level and then
the statement is that
you see how they move the gravitational
field and what they are sensitive to is
really this dual connection so maybe we
should choose that as a fundamental
object
and to my surprise
it was a big surprise that the whole
theory
real general relativity
could be formulated
using this
half the information
somehow
and so so that was a big surprise so
what happened is
two things happen
first of all the theory could be
real generality could be formulated
whereas in twisters even today what we
have is this self-dual sector an
anti-semital sector we don't know how to
combine them whereas in this formulation
we are really talking about real general
activity
and secondly
kinematical level
the the
uh by kinematical level i mean without
before putting the information over the
interactions and so on so i mean
detailed equations uh what are the
variables
uh in terms of which you formulate your
theory in fact in einstein's
autobiographical
notes he has this question that in
formulation of a physical theory the
first question is what tools are you
going to use what are the basic
mathematical variables which are going
to capture your physical ideas and only
then what equations do they satisfy sure
and here the statement is that
these variables are the same for all
interactions that is very
to me it is very satisfying on the other
hand the equation is satisfied quite
different so where does a different
difference come in
another beautiful thing here is that the
difference comes in precisely because
you've got
the
in general relativity there are no
background fields
so when i write down the lagrangian or
the hamistonian in uh young military or
something i'm allowed to use not only
the
the young mills
fields or in the case of maxwell field
i'm not allowed to use not only the 10
select menu or electric and magnetic
fields but also the metric just sitting
there spectator i mean it just is not
doing anything but i mean it's not
dynamically changing it's sitting there
so i can use that to construct this
lagrangian density but here i don't know
anything i don't have a metric
so i had to write down equations
using just these vector potentials right
just
and then the canonical conjugate
variables but i don't have a background
metric you know
now the funny thing is that if you
really give yourself
these these variables this connections
and their conjugate momentum which are
which are like the electric fields
the analog in maxwell theory would be
the electric things
then it turns turns out that there are
very few equations you can write down
and it really literally is true that if
you took a very bright undergraduate or
a first day graduate student and if we
put them in the room and you tell them
write down the simplistic questions you
can write down no micron metric no
background fields all you have is this
connection and it's conjugate momentum
and the equations they will come down
are precisely turned out to be
einstein's equations now this is not how
i arrived at it i did it laboriously
which is i started with the usual
formulation of einstein's equations i
made a canonical transformation
i turned the theory on its head as some
friends of mine told me
and then the statement is that it's
looking at it upside down
so metric is no longer fundamentally
variable and then i did this canonical
transformation you suddenly had these
variables which turned out to be a
connection and that conjugate momentum
and then i looked at i mean because i
just did a canonical transformation i
could write down the equations which are
equivalent to the einstein's equation
only later i realized that there are
other equations you can write down if
you if you have a background
independence and if you want to have
these connections this is the only thing
you can write down
and so that was a formulation of general
relativity
that i started with which gave rise to
this non-particular theory
quantum theory then
so where the advantage of actually using
methods
which are coming from
very successful young military so-called
wilson loops or wilson lines
and those methods were available already
but now we could take it into gravity
and we could interpret
geometry space-time geometry in terms of
those quantities which are used first
only in the context of young military
now much later
i think
a little more than 10 years after i i
did this work and this work was done in
1886
so
about 10 years later i realized i found
out
that in fact both einstein and
schrodinger
had
tried to give um
a formulation of this of general
relativity in which connection would be
a fundamental variable
exactly
the base same basic idea
and it is a very fascinating chapter in
history so i just want to tell it to you
for for sure i have audience
particularly einstein was in
in institute of advanced study in in
princeton
and um
schrodinger was in the history of
advanced study in dublin
and
they
kind of independently thought of this
idea but then they started corresponding
and then these letters are preserved
and i i think that are available in
archives and not
not the usual archive i mean
in the short institute archive
um
and these are uh there's a
correspondence when going back and forth
and this is across the ocean and yet you
know basically the letters are really
one week apart
so
basically as soon as they got the letter
they read it understood it i wrote this
very detail replies to each other it's a
very friendly and jovial thing you know
in which einstein sort of teased
that idea of your was clearer than what
a
devil's grandmother could think of
and and then you know charlie replied
saying that well any these are this is a
bigger honor to me than you know all the
medals that they that kings and various
people have given me and so on so yeah
so this was all happening and they were
working on this theory which was
basically to formulate general
relativity in terms of this connection
but they are using the connection which
is more like the metric connection not
the same dual connection but the
the derivative operator that comes from
the metric up here
and then something happened which is
really there and the weird was that
somehow schrodinger thought that he had
made a breakthrough
and
he
that breakthrough for those of you
audience who might know about it was
basically to drop the condition
that this connection which is sometimes
called christopher symbols
this is crystal symbols normally in
general gtr are symmetric or they call
torsion free so he allowed them to be
anti-symmetric
and he thought that this was really a
revolution
and big idea began and then he gave
press conference saying that well this
is a completely new theory it's much
bigger and much more beautiful
and
you know if in general relativity you
ask them to be symmetric and so you
even give an analogy you say that well
here is a horse and i want to train this
horse but poor horse he cannot do
everything so what i'm going to do is to
train him to jump over a fence
right but i'm going to tie the
hind legs
together
let it
first learn how to do it with his front
legs
and the poor husk won't be able to do it
what you have to do is to you know let
it use all the four legs so so using
that asking that the connect that this
levitivator symbol the connection be
symmetric is like tying the the hind
legs of the horse and i have freed it
now and privately he even discussed that
he might probably get a second nobel
prize and so on so forth
and then he gave a seminar
and at that time you may or may not know
the history but the prime minister
the tisha and then ireland was a
physicist
and so the tisha came to the seminar and
because tisha came to the seminar the
press came to the seminar
and therefore there were headlines the
irish news newspaper and these all by
the way recorded in
various places um
there's a
headlines in irish newspapers saying
that australia has made this great
breakthrough and our generativity is on
this special case and so on and so forth
and then new york times managed to get
their xerox copy of the irish times
before it actually
uh
appeared and sent it to stranger to
oppenheimer and einstein for comments
i don't know any comment of openhead i
just dismissed it completely
but einstein prepared a very careful
reply
and the reply said that
i mean he was very taken aback because
you know they are corresponding on this
idea and suddenly
showing the things that this is this is
a great idea and he didn't think it was
a great idea he didn't think
and so
einstein gave this press release which
said that well
it is unwise for scientists to describe
what is going on in in
technical work in simplistic terms
because that gives it lay public
the impression
that science advances through
revolutions every day as if it was a
banana republic
and this was totally divided and this
appeared of course in new york times
and then this up this was so shocking to
shorten here when you heard about it
schrodinger did the second mistake of
writing to einstein saying that you know
after the war the
living conditions of physicists are so
bad here so you thought that
news like that will you know bring more
money to physics and so on
and einstein never corresponded with
schroedinger after that so he was
offended the schrodinger went off and
said that he found a breakthrough
without conferring with einstein first
so that's it so i mean of course nobody
took experience afterwards the idea i
just died i did not know anything about
it i came to know about it half because
of strangers biography by more i think
it's very very nice of biography and
because i used to visit church institute
in vienna and you know they have this so
there is a there's a box full there
which is
called the moore's biography that it is
it's called the einstein schweinerich
you know the einstein's pick stack i
mean the big mess that he has made in
einstein and this is the whole thing is
so this is an interesting story okay so
this is a long
let's go back to our map
i have a quick naive question there's
something called the fundamental theorem
of romanian geometry so it's if you have
torsion free and something that's
compatible with metric you get a unique
connection so if he throws out the
torsion-free property does the
connection then become ambiguous or like
you make a choice so therefore there are
new degrees of freedom so whatever the
connection so this anti-symmetric part
of the torsion part is really a new
degree of freedom and you thought that
was very important i mean this idea
people are pursued later also it has not
led to anything which is dramatic or
even significant
but i mean it's mathematically it's a
neat idea it's just that
it was not such a revolutionary as it
thought that doesn't mean
so so that coming back to the main point
yeah so coming back to the main point
that the main ingredients were to
formulate general relativity
in turning it upside down making metric
as an emergent quantity
and
and then and then the connection has
been more fundamentally variable
and that is what is now has gone so then
therefore things which are called wilson
lines or bills and loops became basic
variables and the word loop quantum
gravity comes from those wheels and
loops even though these days nobody will
use this loop so much as these lines but
just like string theory you know some
name starts and then it becomes the name
so because string theory there are
brains and there are various other
things which are equally important as
strings but once we still call it string
theory so similarly here it is called
loop quantum gravity
the better type better name would be
something i would say contemporary money
in geometry because if you when you
formulate it in this particular way
then it turns out
that
basic
geometrical objects like
area of this screen that you're looking
at right now
they all become
operators in quantum theory
and these operators have purely discrete
spectrum
and so
really geometry is quantized in the same
sense as
the energy the angular momentum the z
component of angular momentum is
quantized in hydrogen atom
and so this is this is a
important i mean it changes the picture
of geometry completely
and
so this is also something that you don't
see in in other approaches either the
david approach
or the edge spaces and twister or
approach this kind of quantum geometry
and this kind of geometry then has
enormous implications
for big bang black holes
okay here are some thoughts that occur
to me well one is that you mentioned
there's an area operator and then i
recall that there's someone named feman
thomas thiemann who said that we should
have a volume operator and that better
gives a semi classical limit of gr so i
just wanted to know what your thoughts
were on that
right so
i i'm one of the people who introduced
the volume operator studied as detailed
properties so i i mean
greg lewandowski and then
carlo rovelli and lee smolin
independently developed you know the
this volume operator and also the area
operators and so on uh in the beginning
there were difference of opinion there
was some technical error in what carlo
and we had done which is pointed out
bharanathan lol
but you know at the end of it sort of
everything comes together and we have
got a quantum theory of geometry in
which you've got volume up at the area
operator volume operator there's also a
length operator it's just that it's not
as useful as a volume operator in the
length operator
it's also length
and the volume operator is something
that is that plays in what thomas did
the team chiman was a postdoc of mine um
and and not when he
when he began his work this work he was
a postdoc of mine but the specific
papers that he wrote in the series of
papers on this quantum spin dynamics he
started here but then
he finished elsewhere in harvard and
then
he went to
uh
the albert einstein institute that's
very very finished his work up here
so he used this volume operator very
cleverly in order to write
to
give a rigorous formulation of
einstein's uh quantum einstein's
equations
that rigorous formulation is still being
debated it's not completely settled but
there's a huge progress in fact next
month we got this conference in lyon
loops
22
every two years at this conference and
there there is a
there is a talk by
madhuban rajan who has made really
very significant progress on this um
uh formulation quantum einstein's
equation and it does use this volume
operator that you mentioned
again i don't know much about this so my
questions may be fatuous so excuse me so
here's what i understand so you have a
fiber bundle and you have a principle
fiber bundle which for people who are
wondering what that is like attaching a
group to the manifold at each point
okay and there's some compatib there's
some well
the way that i learned it was that you
attach a fiber p and then the p has a
write action and that's g and it's free
yeah yeah yeah okay and and then on that
you place a connection okay then a
yangmill's field
is
is when you take a section and then you
pull back the connection locally
okay so then i'm wondering well what the
heck what is yangville's theory what is
its relationship to that well as far as
i can tell yang mill's theory is just
saying that the lagrangian is somehow
the curvature wedge the hajj form of the
curvature and you take the trace of that
but i don't know if that's if that's all
that there is to yang mills i'm sure
there's more okay no
that's the basic
right exactly
what happens is that almost
most of the play times
that is to say when people apply to find
gaskets space time
the topological considerations are not
important so these bundles are trivial
so you you can
so it's true it's in a cross section of
abundance but if the bundle is trivial
then you can think of it as living in
space-time itself
so most of the time i mean there are
very interesting cases where this is not
the you know you cannot do it and then
you get nice topological results and so
on but when you talk about pathway to
qcd and so on
they're all living just
on space time
you can think of just like maxwell
theory the fields
the strictly speaking maxwell field also
there's a bundle the group there is a u1
group rather than su 3 for example for
gluons here u1 group on the one and it's
the same thing
you can have non-trivial connections but
typically the topology is triggered and
so
you don't worry about it
then what occurred to me was when you
said that the metric is given in the
young mills case whereas in the general
relativity case you you'd
well it's not given and so
okay in the yangmil's case when you say
that it's given is that because you take
the hodge duel and the hodge duel
assumes the metric or is it even more
fundamental than that
all right so you take uh yeah so
eventually yeah exactly the the dual is
so again
it assumes metric only after confirming
factors so young necessity without
matter without quarks or nucleons is
conformally invariant so you can rescale
the metric back and forth factor and the
lagrangian is invariant
okay so now let's say we're on general
relativity and what we have is the
connection then you're wondering well
how do i recover
a metric how do i generate a metric from
this so i don't know how that's done but
i
from what i understand
you're taking the connection and then
you're seeing
what happens when i take it along a path
where i begin and end at the same point
and i know you said that it doesn't have
to be loops but just the way that i'm
understanding it okay so you take the
connection and you bring it along a loop
and then you see and then you integrate
it along a loop
and that gives that tells you how much
connect how much curvature is enclosed
in that reed
yes yes yes and that's called the
hellonomy is that correct hollandamy
approach hold on exactly hold on i mean
so that's how much curvature is in the
most
okay okay so i'm just trying to make
connections make connections between the
academics
exactly
um yeah but i think that's
for us for undergraduates
it might be easier to
sort of so that is certainly true but
there's also sort of a direct way of
understanding
uh constructing kind of spatial metric
the metric is you know in is a spatial
part of the matrix
and that is really that what you do is
to take yangmil's connection that you
got this this
gravitational connection you got and
then you also have the phase space
variables which are electric fields
now normally
electric field is just a vector in in
electromagnetic theory
but if the gauge if you're a gauge group
which is higher dimension in this case
the gauge group is su 2 say
then
you've got kind of it's a matrix value
object it has um
and so it has it's
a vector potential which takes values in
matrices but the values are just su 2
values now so 2 is just three
dimensional is the rotational group
it's a double curve of the rotation
group so you've got x direction rotation
by direction z direction that's the
group that you use for ordinary spinners
in non-relativistic quantum mechanics
the usual because quantum mechanics up
here
and in ordinary spinners you know that
you can just use a basis of power
matrices and so you can think of this
vector that the both the vector
potential and the electric field
as
carrying an internal index one two three
which is basically component or the
first volumetric second parametric third
parliament
so is a vector in space but it also has
an internal index which is like a
like spin is internal space it it lives
in some
abstract space which is not physical
space
and so you got a triplet of
electric fields
and my main idea was that well if you've
got triplet of electric fields then you
can take this triplet yes
and think of it as an orthonormal trial
just defined i mean there's no metric
right so
so given these electric fields three
electric fields i just define
an orthonormal triad with this and then
that defines formula because if i know
what some three or some other vectors
are then that tells me what the i given
any vector i can
decompose into that okay i know uh the
metric so in fact the triad is like a
square root of the metric metric is the
square of the trial just like the
spinners are
square root of vectors
okay interesting interestingness up here
so basically it's really that
cannot the variable which is cannot
canonically conjugate to the tribe that
uh to the connection to the to the
derivative operator of the subject
connection that is what is defining for
you the spatial metric
now this is kind of a little bit of
pedestrian way of doing it but you know
it's more more intuitive
you can do it also covariantly and that
is where the spin forms come into being
but then you have to really think in
terms of
uh the lorenz group at each point
and uh
but i mean it's just like you know
normally how i
explained to you in the very beginning
how
i explained to the undergraduates in the
beginning how given the f f mean u i can
electric and magnetic fields but i can
put them together to get f menu so
similarly what i was just telling you
about now is triad but you can put them
so that you actually get a four
dimensional metric and not just a
three-dimensional entry
and that is that is what is done in spin
forms
when i look at a course on loop quantum
gravity one of the first lessons is on
something called the four legs but it
has a
it has a german name like five bends or
vitrins or
what are those called the tetra are
those tetrads yeah minds are just better
yeah that's german but fear is fear and
behind his legs
okay and that's what you're describing
yeah is that different
okay
and so when you say that
that and i know that i apologize for
people who are wondering like these are
such foolish questions or so or so
technical like what's the point like i'm
just trying to clarify for myself if you
don't mind
so at first when they're being defined
it seems like
it's i was wondering okay so in general
relativity you say okay let me take a
frame let me go along with the frame and
let me just assume that frame's
orthonormal and then when i was hearing
tetra i thought it was just talking
about that but then it sounded like
they're saying
well let me have
another frame with those as the basis
already
no
no no this is it what is that is exactly
that he's just afraid it's just afraid
and when i was talking this internal
indices just his index that
index
this is a zero one two three
right and
but each of them is a vector so there's
a vector
but i'm labeling one zero one two three
so there's there's another index other
than the vector index so there's a
vector index like a mu yes but then
there's also an i if you like and i goes
from zero one to three yeah okay so
that's where i get confused that's where
i initially was confused at least so
let's say you have the four vector and
then you you call them at first like in
the regular general relativity sense
let's call this this e0 e1 e2 e3 but
then i'm saying i'm gonna get another
vector forget about a three that are
orthonormal let's just get take one well
that vector obviously can be decomposed
in terms of these
okay so then you're saying okay kurt
don't just take one vector take another
vector those other indices those are
actually making reference to the
original orthonormal basis
because i was wondering like why why is
there other indices at all why not just
say in the same way you take visas yeah
there's no other index
your confusion was correct i mean there
are no there is no other index i mean
you just assume that there was another
index now i was not referring to another
index at all it's just those that index
no and then the statement is that if you
get two other vectors then i would like
to know for example what is the
magnitude of each of these vectors
or what is the angle between those two
vectors and the statement is that if you
give me the original four vectors which
are e 0 e 1 and 2
then i can just look at the components
of this along
v0 v1 v2 v3 and similarly i can take w
w0 w1 w2 w3
and then i know what the length is the
length is just minus v 0 squared plus v
1 squared plus et cetera and i know what
the angle is it's just v or w v 0 so
that so that's what i mean by saying
that if you give me four vectors
then i know the space time metric if you
give me three vectors then i know the
spatial metric
all right okay so now let's get to the
more fun questions so when you were
working with roger you were a postdoc
under roger when you were working on
this initially and this seems like an
extremely promising approach so is roger
a proponent of loop or did he go off in
another direction yeah so in fact just
recently i had some correspondence with
the philosopher of science who was
visiting oxford he writes to me very
often asking my views and such thing
and so
rogers
raja has not followed it in very much i
mean in his various books he has said
very
positive things about loophole gravity
uh but recently he hasn't sort of kept
up with it so to say
so
you know why do you think that is
he's interested in quantum gravity
yeah but you know everybody has 24 hours
in a day and
you have your own ideas and you feel
that they have more
oh oh okay so he has his own ideas
so he has his own idea i mean the last
15 years or so he has been uh maybe even
more or less the last 10 15 years he has
been
really doing this um
ccc right this or the
confirmation cosmology so that's not
even twisted theory there but it is it
is just back
so he's been focused on that i mean so
it's not
i think this is one this yep i mean but
same thing is true with me i mean i
think that twister theory was very
interesting i started with it i followed
it very very much until um
the
mid or late 1990s but i haven't really
followed the advances on
whatever is happening
are there advances still so there's
someone or some people
moving this twister field forward
yeah there's a smaller group than there
was before but you know particularly
lionel mason oxford is doing very
interesting work on you know scattering
abstinence and sustains using christian
theme
but for me the main i don't see how to
use it very strongly to
ask
to use to address the problems that
interest me for example which has to do
with you know classical general activity
has singularities what happens to them
uh and and
yeah so for those questions i think
twister theory is still very far from
approaching and answering professor what
is einstein's whole argument h-o-l-e
right
so
when eisler was developing this
general relativity
he had this fantastically concentrated
period between
1907 or 8 to 1915 seven or eight years
extremely concentrated period at one
stage
he got stuck because he had this basic
idea that if you give yourself
a theory which has basic variables as i
was saying before and yet decided that
metric was a basic variable
so if you give me some initial data for
the metric at time t t equal to 0
you give all the information that is
needed which is the metric the spatial
metric and it's time derivative
um it's like giving the position and the
velocity of a particle if you like
then
they feel that the field should evolve
and then should actually
give you a solution
but then einstein realized that because
of the coordinate
freedom in general relativity
this is not true
i could give myself
a metric at the initial instant of time
and it's time derivative
technically
extrinsic curvature is what it's called
it is about how this
three manifold sits in the four manifold
that is the time derivative of the
metric
um then he found that well the solution
is not unique because i could you could
construct one solution
and i can come
and make a little motion what is that
mathematically called the diphemorphism
or
in pedestrian language we call a
coordinate transformation
and that coordinate transformation or
differmorphism
is identity everywhere except in some
region up here
so you started out here
and at the initial time you fixed your
surface completely
you're not touching it so the initial
data is exactly the same
but i just changed the metric up here we
have the femorphism or coordinate
transformation
which is
identity outside but it's not identity
in some related region here and that is
a whole hole e
then there is again a solution of
einstein's equations
so somehow there wasn't a one-to-one
correspondence between specification of
the initial data and the solution
and therefore for a while he really was
completely
you know stuck with this and saying that
something wrong how do we get out of it
or something until the realization came
that in fact
you don't get a unique solution you get
a unique solution modulo for net
transformation or modular different
modifications which identity on the
initial slice because you fix the
initial data
and so
the coordinates
or coordinate levels of a point don't
have as really a physical significance
they're gauge dependent quantities it's
like the vector potential in in
electromagnetism if you like or
um
young military i mean there's a gauge
freedom there so in young men's theory
also it's not true or electromagnetism
that if you give me a
electric field sorry the the vector
potential and the electric field the
electric field is like time derivative
of the vector potential it's like the
velocity
i get a solution but the solution is not
unique i can make a gauge transformation
i can take the vector potential
and add to it the gradient gradient of a
function then function is zero
everywhere except in some related
regions and that is that is equally a
good solution
so we should not ask that the vector
potential should be unique we should
find out what the observables are
and the observers should take unique
values so in electromagnetic magnetism
it's simple just calculate the electric
and magnetic fields
and then they are unique there's no
problem with the electric and magnetic
fields at all
and now
so the question is about what about
general relativity
things are conceptually subtle
and then
the reason is because
we don't have a simple observables
because
you usually take tensorfields and you
calculate the
values in terms of components
and the coordinates themselves don't
have meaning so you have to construct
invariant quantities so you can take for
example curvature and contract all these
indices of the metric and that is
invalid that would not change at all
so if you could
choose i mean just conceptually this in
practice nobody has been able to do it
and
it's not going to be very useful either
but if you could choose four curvature
in variance you know richer than it's a
square it one takes a square with the
scalar curvatures
which are independent from each other
there are no algebraic relations between
them and if you use them as a
coordinates
and express everything in terms of these
invariant quantities
then the solution will be unique
so this is what einstein realized that
in fact there is a gauge freedom and you
we just have to live it
and so that is the whole argument
basically and this whole argument
actually has
a very interesting
thing in loop on gravity because what
are the basic tenet of group quantum
gravity is again that these points don't
have
physical meaning or the coordinate
labels that don't have physical meaning
you should not have background
structures
so you have to compute observables
you you cannot just ask
for example i cannot ask i should not
ask what is the area of the screen by
itself right as a mathematical i mean
mathematically i can ask an object right
but i should ask the question formulate
the question
in physical terms namely
the screen is invariantly defined
as a discontinuity surface
there is no matter on this side of
screen
and then suddenly there is a
discontinuity right there is matter here
on the straight side so i define this
screen as a discontinuity surface
and then i can ask what is the area of
this surface
now if i make a coordinate
transformation it acts on the metric
but it also acts
on the matter field
it acts on everything there are no
spectators in this in this drama of
evolution so if i make a coordinate
transformation if i make an ephemerism
the femorphism is an active way of
talking about coordinate transformation
then this screen for example would bend
would become some look like that
but the metric were also bad
and the value of the area that the new
metric will give on the new screen
is the same as what the first metric
gave me on the screen so this is an
observable the area of the screen is an
observer
and the reason is because matter as well
as geometry are both actors
and differentisms act on them both
simultaneously
okay you gave away that the question
made sense and then didn't make sense
can you restate the first way in which
it doesn't make sense
yeah
so if i just say that well
very good so if i just say that well
here is a
certain square right what is this area
and the statement is that well i don't
know because if i take the square and if
i act on by differmorphism
then i will get a metric
right
and
i i the same metrics that is given to me
then i calculate this area and the area
is going to be different okay okay
but the point is because you know the
area is not invariant
the metric is not invariant in different
marks
but what you have to do is to define the
surface in physical terms
and apply the diffumorphism to
everything
metric is the physical quantity so you
apply the thermomorphism the metric
and you apply the diffusion to this math
thing right you apply them
simultaneously i mean and then it's
completely impacting and that is very
deeply embedded in the quantum gravity
our observable observables that we talk
about
are observables in this sense and these
are relational observables i think carlo
must have talked about this
this relational view is very very
important in in gravity
i mean the view is already there in
classical general activity but we take
it very seriously much more seriously
okay so we just talked about einstein's
whole argument which is not talked about
much so i i don't think anywhere else on
the internet actually i did a youtube
search and so this will be one of the
only videos where einstein's whole
argument is referenced by the way i just
signed your mock you know when i first
i saw it
it's a personal thing when i first read
this argument there were tears in my
eyes really i mean this guy where was he
born how could he figure this out you
know
it was really so deep and so beautiful
and you know figuring this out and then
finally first of all being confused
about itself is
yes yes it is an act of you know
my genius right not normal people would
not even
understand the issues
why don't we stick for a moment longer
on the einstein whole argument the way
that it was explained was you have some
system and then you evolve it forward
and then there's a whole
and and it doesn't matter if the hole is
is here or non-existent or it's larger
it still gives the same observable now
can you make that more concrete in terms
of let's say there's a ball in terms of
newtonian if you throw a ball what would
it be like like give people an analogy
like it would be like if the solution is
a parabola we understand but the
solution could also be a parabola minus
the top like give some analogy now the
probability that there's no analogy
in italian in terms because there's no
notion of gauge
notion of gauge is critical in in in
this thing so anytime you have like
newtonian argument or
the newtonian ball or something like
that there it is true that every initial
data
your you have got newton's laws every
initial data gives right so trajectory
that's the end of it
you can't change the trajectory out here
because there's no emotional gauge and
but in maxwell theory there is so i can
give that example using maxwell theory
but it is already a little bit abstract
which is basically that i can give you
the initial data of the vector potential
and its time derivative which is the
electric field i can evolve it and i get
a solution but i can take take a little
ball i mean little regional space little
hole and in that region i just change
the vector potential by vector potential
it goes to its original value plus
gradient of a function because the
vector and i'll take a gradient of any
function
when i do that
the vector potential itself in that
little region has changed
but you'll see that it continues to
satisfy the equation
uh that was
that the vector paradigm so that's
satisfied
so
the point is that
you should not try to
to see if the uniqueness holds for the
vector potential but for observables
and the observable for the map for the
max in this case is a magnetic field is
a curl of this a
and when i take the curl the gradient
drops out
the curl of a and curl of a plus
gradient of f is exactly the same
so the e and b are exactly the same in
maxwell theory and that gauge in varying
quantities and they are exactly the same
it's just that in physics sometimes you
you think well i should be able to
formulate thing all in terms of gauging
bad in quantities i was
sure that was possible when i was a
student but i know the statement is that
if you wanted local physics and that's
locality locality's important part here
then i would we don't know that they
cannot be formulated engage in value i
mean
manifestly gauge in varying fashion
in e m the potential is not observable
it's the electric in the magnetic field
yeah electric magnetic however isn't
there the arium or the iron off bomb
effect that
exactly so the statement okay so how
does so how does one make sense of the
whole argument there
yeah well it's similar but not exactly
the same because there's no initial data
which is you are evolving in the
marijuana effect so what you have is
solenoid so i mean when you think of
this as a solenoid just forget about
yeah this is a solenoid and then the
statement is that there's a you know
current going through here and so
therefore you i carefully adjust it so
that actually there is no
um uh that the magnetic field is all
here
zero magnetic field okay outside here
okay and then the interesting thing is
that
i
see the what the electron does if i
start out here where there is zero
magnetic field and i go around
and the statement is that there is
actually a zero magnetic field so you
might say that nothing happens yes yes
but
the statement is that
there is in fact the following if you
like i mean you actually do get
a defect up here because the vector
potential here is not zero okay so it's
not right to say that vector point is
not observed certain quantities are
observable why
because if i what you are you're
measuring is what you say hologram which
is really the the the circuit integral
of a e dot okay
okay but a dot dl is the same as b dot s
by by strokes here right if i take
a
vector potential up here and do the
circuit integral
is the same as
doing the surface integral
the flux of the magnetic field
through this surface up here and there
is so but you have to take the whole
surface which is enforced by this and
that does include here so the electron
doesn't see the surface but the electron
actually sees and so that is a beautiful
argument to say that well if you wanted
to formulate everything in local terms
then the vector potential is essential
right because magnetic field was zero
here the magnetic field was zero but the
electron still felt the electromagnetic
field
and the reason is because there was a
flux of magnetic field that is enclosed
by this search
so that locality
requires us to introduce these variables
like
which are not gauging variant
but
this the circuit integral of a
of
a dot dl which is hollow me is gauging
married
and
okay another aspect that's not talked
about much is mock's principle there are
very few videos online about mock's
principle
so why don't you explain what mock's
principle is why einstein thought it was
so crucial and what loop quantum gravity
says about it
okay
so
the coin marks principle or marks
conjecture was actually this term was
coined by einstein
it didn't exist before so mark's never
called it a principle or something it
was really going by his time at that
time and it played an important role in
his formulation of
ideas about gender relativity
and
this really goes back to newtonian ideas
about inertial frames and so on
and
at that time in newtonian theory it is
certainly true that you know
things like notion of centrifugal force
very very important if you're rotating
then in your arms go out or
if you're doing a solid spinner the
water goes out you know you dry the
salad up here
in that particular way so
if you are not an inertial frame if
you're in a rotating frame then there is
a centrifugal force it looks like the
notion of rotation is an absolute notion
but in neutron in theory there was there
are local inertial frames
and so the question was well then you
know how can you tell which the frame is
locally inertial and are you rotating or
are you not rotating
and then the idea was that well you look
at the distance stars
and this
the frame defined by the distant stars
is is an inertial frame
um and then on the other hand the local
so if you're rotating with respect to it
then i'll be showing a picture of the
newtonian bucket thought experiment and
as far as i understand newton's use that
to say no there is an absolute notion
i'm sorry yes there is absolute space or
an absolute notion of motion and then
someone else named mock took it and said
actually that same experiment proves
that motion is relative except you have
to take into account something else
right
namely that it's really related to the
digital stars and it is really defined
by yeah
so mark wanted to say the distance and
so the idea was that well non-local
things i mean things out of there
determine the the local leader kind of
thing and that idea of sort of uh
einstein in his writing and so on has
emphasized that that played an important
role but in later years i think that
there is some work
uh historical nice digging of work by
historians of science maybe julian
barber from the other people
then einstein himself has said that no
as a mathematical sense in
mathematical terms mark's principle
doesn't make any sense
and his physical content is very weak
this decided later later why is that the
case okay so the reason is because of
the following thing
so so the upshot of that is that you
know
as far as i know most general literary
people don't think that that principle
plays a
deep role or any role in the it depends
on who you talk to in the in actually
final theory that einstein came away
which is why you basically which is why
i never heard of it until recently and
i've studied general relativity and i've
been taught courses in it and almost no
one else that i that's a student knows
about mark's principle
and the main point is that
i'm the only way to formulate it is
something and that's that's i don't get
too
technical but basically again in terms
of this initial value formulation that
we talked about namely
some of those einstein's equations that
we have got
uh i i i stands there are 10
the metric has 10 components and i got
10 einstein's equations on the metric
and einstein's equation relate the
curvature to
the stationary tensor or
to matter properties okay
and the thing is that
four of those equations are called
constrained equations in other words
they don't involve time derivatives
so they must involve just phase
derivatives so they must hold at an
instant of time without knowing what the
time derivatives are okay
um and as an example is just given by in
electromagnetism you can think of e and
b
and you got equations and you have got
equation which says that divergence of e
is equal to 0 and diverges
without sources divergence of equal to 0
and the inversions of b equal to 0. if
you have sources then reverse of e is
equal to 4 by times charge density
but then they don't involve any
time derivatives but then you've got
time derivative equations which says
that e dot the time derivative is curve
b and v dot is minus curly so you get
uh you get a
how things evolve but there are
equations so but you better make start
by making sure that your initial data is
such that divergence of e is equal to
zero and inverses of b is equal to zero
now the same thing is true einstein's
case there are four equations which are
called constraint equations and
mathematically they're called elliptic
equations
so elliptic equations are very rigid you
know you cannot just
the solutions are really given globally
on an initial instant of time
and so if you give me a stationary
tensor matter field then i will be able
to calculate for you
uh i i have to solve this equation to
get the the
initial metric in the extensive
curvature there is still some freedom
but a lot of it is completely determined
and some so sometimes people might say
that well so there is max principle
because
you know matter doing out there is
determining what the solution here could
be
but that's not completely right because
you also have local degrees of freedom
that matter doesn't determine this
solution completely i mean you know
and and then of course if you say that
then you would have to say also in the
electromagnetism right that there's a
max principle somewhat charge density
out there determines what the you know
what the electric field up here is uh
and the statement is that yes or no yes
in the sense that if there are no
electromagnetic waves then the answer is
yes if it's a static solution then the
answer is yes but if there are
electromagnetic waves
then part of the electric field is
determined by these sources charges but
part of it is just it has its own
degrees of freedom and gravitational
field has its own degrees of freedom
and so
that's one of the reasons why people
don't take it seriously i personally
also don't take it seriously but i may
be a
not a total minority but somewhat of a
minority because i think that the whole
notion of inertial frames which are so
important
yes in autonomy physics the whole point
of general relativity was that it's lost
right and you don't have
i mean you can
for your intuition you can talk about
local inertial frames but i think that
you can do any every calculation answer
every physical question without ever
talking about initial frames
and so this whole impetus that
that was there about you know what how
do you know that you're inertial
framework you're not yeah
i mean since you're talking about
undergraduates i mean the
i mean
you know when it is elementary course
there's always smart i i feel there's
some smart undergraduate should ask this
question right he said wait a minute you
calculated
the
motion of the moon
around the earth
saying that
well i mean the earth center of mass i
mean
it's
it's an inertial frame and in that i
applied beta's laws and i solved it
but then earth's frame was inertial fine
but then when you try to talk about
earth's motion around sun
then you say sun's frame is inertial and
earth is rotating
if earth is rotating it could have been
universal frame so isn't one of your
calculations wrong
and to me at least i mean the real
answer to this real answer to this
question comes from general relativity
that you don't need the notion of
initial frame you're just calculating
geodesics
in the two cases and then there's no
problem at all so i think this whole ore
emphasis on inertial frame i don't mean
it's useless notion yes yeah yeah sure
on the other hand it's not
essential it's not something that you
know in which any foundation issue
should refer to so
that is the point about mass principle
okay so let's get to
black holes
what does loop quantum gravity say about
singularities and black holes it would
also be great if you could outline what
a singularity is and why there are
problems or some people think they're
issues with the concept of them
so actually singularities in general
relativity
or any theory are really arise because
you start with some initial data which
is completely regular and you evolve it
using field equations
and it may turn out that the field
equations say that in fact
after a finite time
the fields become infinite and if the
field becomes infinite you cannot evolve
any further
right and then you are stuck and me just
have no no no
so it's like the theory fails there
there it comes to an end there
now
something like that may happen in other
theories but one might just say that
well it's not so bad because after all
maybe i just need to tweak something and
for that particular theory i mean i
still have space time you know i can ask
the question about evolving and such
thing but in general activity the space
time itself is defined by this evolution
so if the field becomes singular the
curvature diverges somewhere
then space-time itself comes to an end
so it's not just
that particularly initial data
relate to a problem but in that space
time
everything ends maximum freelance quark
and everything else there so that's why
singularity of general relativity
particularly the ones which are
so-called space-like singularities where
everything else
are kind of
to some people troubling to some people
like me that gates
to physics beyond einstein so there are
opportunities maybe they are not that i
mean this is very good for me
um
so
historically what happened was the
following so i think this is important
for people to know
that historically people started
by
um
with cosmology right
namely the
freedom of solution the initial
singularity so the universe is starting
with the singularity up here after
hubble's discovery and by the way it is
really
la metro understood the physics of it
completely the the
the
observation of what it meant and so on
so forth and that's why the
hubble
law was renamed
recently by the astronomers
so
there was actually this initial
singularity right
and that means that if we evolve back in
time space time comes to an end and so
there was an absolute beginning
and this was
a issue about you know big contention
and they were
people were thinking both ways right
maybe
some people
thought that well this is good because
that means that you know the biblical
notion of you were starting at a finite
time is is
is reinforced by science
and if you what you would like to again
a very interesting anecdote here is that
george gamma who was one of the leading
physicists at that time who was working
on nuclear synthesis
and the notion of big bang really became
more established with nuclear synthesis
that there must have been a
very hot phase of the early universe in
which heavy elements were cooked because
somehow when you look at the abundance
of um
lithium helium
and
that somehow and see how much of its
production starts
that is not really something that could
be
produced in stars you know enough of it
would not be furious time there must be
some initially
uh
there was some other mechanism about
which this was produced and therefore
there was a heart initial phase in the
universe so gamma actually wrote to
for pius
14 i think
um at that time and
saying that well look you know
you know the hot phase of the universe
universal
was also born and pope got very excited
and uh
so he
next
the vatican has a nice observatory so
the next conference that came
the pope inaugurated by saying that it
isn't just wonderful the science and
religion are coming together and so on
so forth
and la metro who was associated with
observatory had the good spot to go to
the pope and with the
one senior person and convince the po
that it's best not to mix religion and
science
and keep the two things completely
separately and the interesting thing
that he was successful because pope
never
referred to this again
that was very interesting
so the singularities are very very
important but people had you know
various
knees about it and
in the 70s you know very british very
prominent british
physicists and astronomers
came up with this steady state
university you know hermann bondi was
worth working on it
and of course fred hoyle was the name
pushing uh jared narliker was a student
of his
um
so
they were actually
pushing this idea and in papad because
some people didn't feel that big bang
was
in fact the name big bang was by the way
people don't know
was invented by
fred hoyle
in a pejorative way in the sense of
making fun of it i'm not serious
so
so the statement is that this big singer
this thing initial singularities were
troubling so that is really the absolute
beginning of
time
and black holes at least the
the simplest black holes the choices
black holes and so on they represent the
absolute end of time
because space time ends there and yeah
you cannot evolve classical generality
fails and you cannot evolve not only
classical general activity but you know
you cannot involve any field there
because every
inaudible space and time it space notion
of space and time breaks down there so
that is why it is so uh
sort of uh important the reason i spend
a lot of time explaining about the big
bang
rather than right away in black folks is
because
for majority of the period in in history
people were more worried about the you
know this absolute beginning than the
absolute in part because it's relatively
recently that people began to accept
black holes as being reality writing so
again younger undergraduates won't
realize this but
it is really true i mean i think
when i was a graduate student i had
somebody was a couple of years ahead of
me john friedman and he
went to
give talks he was a student of chandra
shekhar's and they were talking about
black holes and in very prominent
universities prominent physicists would
ask him afterwards why are you working
on this right it's not mathematically
it's not physical but
astronomers also didn't take it
seriously for the longest time so that's
why i began with the i mean the single
guy yeah he has been with us but
troubling a lot of people for a long
time
which is which is the cosmological big
banks and that's a meta commentary on
the state of physics because some people
would wonder well why do you care about
high energy phys or extremely high
energy physics when we can't reach there
when it seems like there's no
predictions and so on well the same
argument was laid at black hole theory
or studying black holes you know i agree
but i mean the question is always how
how compelling the argument is and again
how comparing the argument is in the eye
of the beholder right i mean to me as a
graduate student and you know people who
are doing generativity is obvious
there are a lot of black holes or
something out of the obvious like why
don't we see them well we don't see that
because you know we don't have the
techniques so we'll see them
we're confident about it all i mean
something i was 100 confident about it
otherwise you would not have spent 10
years of his life thinking about these
things
okay so that's what singularity is now
the so the
so for the longest time then right
people have believed that the
singularity is the artifacts of gender
relativity
because we are assuming that einstein's
field equations are valid at arbitrary
high densities and highly high
curvatures
now people don't realize this but
already
in the 50s in one of the editions which
i have in one of my papers
einstein's
book
meaning of relativity uh one of the
later editions he has an explicit
statement saying one may not assume
the the big bang singularity
to be physical he doesn't call it big
bang it says the initial singularity to
be to be
this is it
one should not assume that the the big
the initial singularity in the
mathematical sense to be physical
because one
one may not assume the field equations
which is his own equations uh at
arbitrarily high densities of matter and
field by feeling curvature
so eister himself outside that by the
way but i mean people still took it all
very seriously but i think there's a
complete general consensus now that
there is the
uh that this big bang is an artifact of
pushing generativity beyond its domain
of validity ah i see i see
is it correct to say that for the same
reason that we can't evolve a black hole
forward and so we say that that's the
quote-unquote end of space-time is that
the same reason why we consider the big
bang to be the quote-unquote beginning
in terms of just evolving it backward we
can't
i mean yeah in both those cases i'll
qualify the minute but that's that's
that's the idea that's like okay
so right now that's exactly right both
of those
and i just wanted to say that there is
like again for undergraduates there is a
short video
which is called the meaning of the big
bang or the new meaning of the big bang
or something like that it's the only
shot it's quite short like 15 20 minutes
sometime that's all and there were about
seven of us were interviewed because
including stephen hawking and roger
penrose and
and we were interviewed as a completely
separate location in our home
institutions and so
we did not know who else was being
interviewed what they were saying and we
all had different approaches to quantum
gravity and so on but then all of us say
the exactly the same thing that big bang
is not a physical singularity
you know there's a early hot phase of
the universe
that everybody agrees with that is
important for nuclear synthesis and so
on and so forth but this in the
inflationary model for example
this phase comes after
the end of inflation
so certainly not before the onset of
inflation right before the big bank at
all
and people will say that well yeah
the idea that
in early days you know when people found
cosmic microwave background and so on
they said well this is the signature of
the big bang you know and that i think
is not is it's not correct at all
there's a statement here it's not a
signature big bang because it happened
after i mean the the hot phase must
happen
way after as in
many seconds or many microseconds or
whatever
no i think it's not way after it's not
that often uh yeah so it's about um
fraction of a second but yeah
in terms of planck times the way after
fraction yes yes yes 10 to 30 plant
times 10 to the 38 times something like
that which is in that sense will be
after
even even more i mean
the end of inflation is then then after
that how many falls passed before the
uh
reheating starts uh it's it's a little
bit uncertain exactly how much yeah so
you could say
of the order of seconds
because there's some uncertainty about
when exactly the eating start started
and how long it lasts also so that is
the phase at which that is the heart
phase of the of the universe all right
so
yeah
so that's that is idea and then the
statement is that
what
does loop kind of gravity wants to have
to say about this
and this has been one of the sort of
solid ideas in loop quantum gravity
namely
that
because we have got
quantum ramanian geometry rather than
classical demanding geometry
so we have to reformulate einstein's
equations in this new language
i like to say that well quantum gravity
needs a new syntax
and in loop quantum gravity the new
syntax
is
contemporary money in geometry
and now when you formulate einstein's
equation in terms of contemporary money
in geometry
there are difficulties of course and
that's why the problem is not completely
solved but
what we can do is to
go to physically interesting situations
and apply it there it's a bit like
we don't still have a complete qcd
theory a quantum chromodynamics theory
but we can go to physically interesting
situations and
you develop approximation techniques and
then make predictions and then there's
same concern and such such thing
so here
the simple examples are simple
situations that are physically
interesting are
uh provided
by cosmology so the big bang and the
black holes right and there are
simplices
and then
the reason why things that are important
but also there is a lot of symmetry and
because there's a lot of symmetry then
loop quantum gravity can make a lot of
progress because many of these questions
then simplify i mean technical questions
technically just simplify that
so
that area is called loop quantum
cosmology
and
the way loop quantum cosmology is done
compared to other quantum cosmologists
is really keeping an eye
to full quantum gravity so it's true
that one is in a simplified situation
but one doesn't sort of
say that i don't know what the full
theory is and i'll just work in this
simplified situation this is what
happens in wheeler david cosmologist
because in the full theory there is no
um
mathematically conceptual framework we
don't have hilbert space we don't know
what to do and so on so forth right even
in the kinematic level even before you
come down to dynamical equations
what is the basic framework in terms of
which to pose the questions is not clear
in
geometry dynamics whereas in low quantum
gravity we have this rigorous framework
this quantum demand in geometry produces
for provides us this rigorous framework
therefore we can take this rigorous
framework and apply it in the simplified
situations and there's a precise sense
there are real theorems we say that
that this applied to this particular
situation there you've got a certain
representation certain way certain
hilbert spaces certain ways of
representing operators
those ways trickle down to these
particular ways of doing operators i'm
not saying there are no ambiguities but
they have i mean that their theorems
will tell you what the assumptions are
so they will tell you what the ambiguity
is but they're higher order things
and within this the statement is that
uh
loop quantum gravity has a very
look on cosmology has a precise
mathematical framework
and precisely because it encapsulates
the quantum nature of geometry the fact
that the area operator has a discrete
spectrum plays a very important role in
this case
because of that
quantized i sorry classical einstein's
equations receive quantum corrections
and these kind of corrections are such
that
the evolution of the of icelandic of
quantum intense equation doesn't break
down in the singularity you can continue
across it
so
you can look at it at various levels at
a heuristic level
you can think of it as follows
this is space-time continuum is an
approximation and i've given this very
often analogy because i think it really
is a good analogy which is that you look
at for example
my my shirt up here and my shirt up here
is really
for all practical purposes this is
two-dimensional continuum you want some
see it's continuing it's clear it's
convenient
but you just have to take a magnifying
glass and see that it is is opened by
one dimensional threads there are
constituents it's not a continuum it's
really is one dimensional it's not two
dimension but the threads are packed
together so much that it looks like a
two-dimensional container
and the statement is that the same is
true with the quantum
remaining geometry
namely our space-time continuum is an
approximation like this sure
there are fundamental building blocks
and these four level building blocks i
come from these wilson lines of these
connections up here and the precise
mathematical framework that is what
enables you to calculate the spectrum
the eigenvectors i and i get values of
the area operator the volume after the
length operator and so on so forth
and what one finds is that the length
that the area
has a non-zero minimum value
so it's not a continuous thing because
it is the spectrum is discrete you've
got zero of course but then there's a
gap
and then there's smallest eigen value
and that is called the area again
and then when you go to contaminants
equations this area gap
plays a fundamental role
i again let me make a detour because
you've talked about because just a while
ago
and we talked about the bombardment
effect which is also harmony so what
golonam it does is to really look at the
flux of curvature so one way of defining
the curvature
is really in terms of
in terms of holograms
and the statement is that
you you have to take the holonomy and
you have to divide by shrinking the loop
until it shrinks to zero in classical
general activity
but in quantum real money enjoyment you
you don't do that you you you can only
shrink it up to a minimum area eigen
value
and when you have shrunk it to a minimum
eigen value
then you get an operator and there is a
fundamental non-locality for this
curvature operator but at the plank
scale it's not because this area that
encloses the order of plants sorry
there's a non-locality associated with
what
there's non-locality in the curvature
operator so the curvature is defined by
taking
the polynomial around the closed loop
and dividing it by the area like it's
because the volume of electromagnetic
field would be b
magnetic field times area b dot ds
and then if you don't know what the
magnetic field here is you want to
divide by area and take the limit so the
loop particular point okay
but here we i mean you cannot shrink it
to zero value because there's there's a
there's a minimum so you shouldn't get
to the spectrum starts at a non-zero
value
or respect there is a zero value but
then the statement is that
the
you cannot shrink this loop to a zero
value i mean if you try if you shrink it
to the zero value there is no i mean the
the the framework doesn't let you
because it's discrete or
it's discrete it's discrete exactly it's
discrete the spectrum is discrete so you
come to the minimum non-zero value
and then the statement is that you have
this holonomy that gives you
the
the curvature
times if you like this area right i mean
but that's all you have
you cannot have curvature at a point you
just have we have these operate so
there's a therefore there's a
non-locality at the plank scale because
all you have is a helon army which is
like i don't know besides that what the
value of the curvature is at this little
point where am i pointing the finger
but i know the average curvature value
in this blank scale and sorry to be
clear when you say that there's
non-locality are you referring to the
connection changes from point to point
is that what you mean or is something
different no the connection does change
point to point but the statement is that
the curvature
is calculated only by the connection
only in terms of this wilson loops
and therefore i cannot define
the
the the formalism doesn't does not let
me define the coverage at a given point
it only tells me what the curvature is
average culture occur which it is
on the surface of plankton
along the whole enemy so in terms of
surface average culture curvature is in
a plank plank area yeah my mistake i was
thinking i was mistaking local and
non-local at the same time okay
this is not local at a plant scale it's
not
like belgian equality so this is very
very our epr paradox is very very low
known
but but the statement i just i'm saying
this because you brought up the no the
notion of poland a while ago yeah
so therefore what happens is the
curvature also has a maximum value it
cannot be infinite in the column there's
a maximum value
and that maximum value
not surprisingly is related to the area
again
the matter density has a maximum value
and the matter density is which which
which is is really given by
the
goes like some constants divided by the
area gap two
now if you let the area gap go to zero
it might be the classical limit then the
maximum value becomes infinite but in
loop quantum gravity area gap is a very
defined number and therefore you've got
a maximum it's a very large number right
sure sure
that's fine but the precise number is
fine exactly
and therefore in loop quantum drive in
glucoram
what you do is you take a wave function
of the universe
in other words you first start out the
classical space type
classical solution of einstein's
equations like one of the
friedman lumetri roberts and walker
cosmologist
and then you take a wave function which
is very sharply peaked on that geometry
at a given instant of time
at later
so that wave function describes the
geometry and you evolve it back in time
and as you evolve it back in time it
remains sharply peaked
along some geometry
if you want it forward in time it
remains sharply peaked around geometry
is the classical solution that is okay a
function
but if you evolve back in time
then it follows the classical solution
until the matter density or the
curvature is about 1000 or 10 000 times
upon curvature
and then it deviates
so the coordinate correction becomes
very important it's almost negligible
until the planet density is
about
10 000 times or 1000 times the that's a
matter density is 10 000 or thousand
times the plant density
until then the classical generality is
an excellent approximation all right
interesting okay
and what this means is basically that
the classical trajectory is still in the
peak of the wave function you know the
wave function is sharply peaked the
classical wave trajectory still is still
in that in that wave function
you know what one standard deviation of
the wavelength
but then when that density is reached
then
the wave bay packet
is still sharply peaked but does not
follow the classical trajectory
classical trajectory will run into
singularity
so if i think about singularity as being
on the left side here and the classical
trajectory is going into singularity
left side here and the classical
trajectory is going into the singularity
right it's just
your right side classical structures are
used in singularity what happens that it
is approaching approaching approaching
singularity and then bounces
it bounces away from the singularity
and again by the time
the curvature becomes one thousand
that's a thousand times
one upon thousand times the planck
curvature or density is about one upon
thousand times plunk density
then classical general duty classical
general relativity is again a good
approximation
so there is a quantum bridge which joins
a
pre big bang branch of the universe the
post big bang branch
so that is what is happening
and to me the big surprise was when i
first found it found this out i
didn't believe this right
you know i saw that better maybe this is
very special because we're using very
special wave functions especially
initial conditions so i was working with
two post docs um
thomas pawlowski and param singh
and we
i met and they were the ones who were
doing the hark and the calculation the
computations not the
the analytical part i've done most of
them a lot of it
but
and so i kept asking them to change
these parameters do this do that to see
if it is robust and after about
six or eight months
i was convinced that you know it's
really there it's not and then a couple
of years later we found analytical
methods to get the same results with our
appropriate approximations so now by now
there are many many different
ways
that
of checking this result that in fact the
wave function does bounce
and you get uh
is this what's called the ashtakar
bounce
i it's called the quantum bonds i don't
know maybe it doesn't okay okay when i
was speaking to
salvator pius and i know i sent you
a question from him he kept referring to
the astrocar bounce and he was saying
kurt you have to read
so i think that's true that i was
saying you have to read conversations on
quantum gravity ashtakar will blow your
mind he told me read all the
conversations except yours and leave
yours for last because he said yours is
the best one and he was super excited so
at some point later we'll get we're
going to get to his question
all right so that is what happens and
and then cosmological models people have
done many things first it was done just
by the simplest models which are
specially flat which correspond to
observed universe seems to be especially
flat but then you know to make sure it
is robust people i added special
curvature to it people have added
inflationary potentials to it people i
added an isotropic to it and
collectively where i found that the
bounce is very robust
now nonetheless in cosmology things are
reasonably simple because of a very high
degree of symmetry
when it comes to black holes it is the
same question
as you say is the end of the universe
and as opposed to the beginning of the
universe for at least for non-rotating
black holes i will talk about rotating
black holes just in a minute
um
so non-rotating black holes are
singularity against space like so it is
really like the big bang singularity but
it's in the future its nature is very
different
the part of the curvature which blows up
at the big bang is very different from
the part of the curvature which blows up
at the black
and that is why penrose often refers to
the
two as being very different and
therefore they should be handled
differently and so on and so forth
um so what so therefore as a result we
do not have as many tests and as much
detailed investigation
in the black hole case as we have in the
big bang case
but there are a fair number of
calculations of having said that they
appeared in physical letters people have
a lot of references people you know
build on it and not just
you know hundreds of papers written on
the basis of those and so on so it's not
um
it's not a beginning stage by any means
but it's certainly also not not not
really finished
so what do we know
so there again
what we find is that it is somewhat
different but we find is that there is
actually
a bounce
right across in your eyes so
the universe doesn't end
at the
singularity of the shots in space time
but you can actually continue
the the evolution across that
singularity
now
what is it that happens what are the
differences
well
the black hole case as you know
there is an exterior region which is the
normal region that we live in and so on
so forth and there is a regional black
hole inside the horizon
and here what we are doing is to look at
the region inside the eyes
because the singularity is inside the
horizon up here
and so
you look at that region inside the
horizon and then then you evolve and
then let's see what happens
but inside the horizon
is called a trapped region the reason is
because light is trapped
so basically think of the horizon as
being you know this is a style
and this is space so i think of the
horizon as being a null surface like
that
and therefore if i
light a beam of light up here
normally
the beam of light
would actually expand out
and there will be part which also goes
inside the light bulb so it contracts
but we what we see is the one which is
expanding up so inside the black hole
the expanding branch actually contracts
and that is why it's called a trap
region so this expanding
what would be normally a light front
which is expanding is actually
contracting and goes into singularity
so inside the horizon
both the
outgoing branch and then going
outgoing light front and then going like
they're both contracting
they're both contracting
therefore that region is called the trap
tree where
expansion of both light both
outgoing and incoming
is negative because
this because it's contracting okay
and what we find is that there is a
when you say contracting so the way that
i'm visualizing it is with ordinary
space-time type diagrams and then the
cones they're just pointing toward the
black hole there's only clones point
okay
but but once we are inside the black
hole the
inside the black color up here already
we're inside the black so
what you're saying is usually people
draw those diagrams when they're outside
but now where are you inside them oh i
see i said wounds are all
sort of
the codes are pointing just straight
into singularity
nothing goes out right because that that
region is stacked
so if the singularity is at the top of
the page up here right that means it's
in the top of the page then the
statement is that these
if if i got this this is a horizon the
light rays coming from here
just go and hit the singularity and
that's it okay okay they never came did
they ever reach you on the horizon they
just
uh so that light front is not expanding
out that light trend is actually
contracting and there's there's this
contracting goes into the horizon
so it's area of that light normally if i
light light light bulb spherical light
bulb then the area the light front is
expanding at the speed of light right
here the area of that light front is
actually contracting inside and that is
why it's called a trapped region or
contracting
and then what happens is that you come
across a space like surface which was a
singularity before is now replaced by a
regular surface
but this surface is a transition surface
and on the other side what you have
is really
anti-traction
in which both light fronts
are outgoing both light fronts are
expanding
in normal
like in your room in my room if i were
to write a right light like you know and
strike a match or light light bulbs and
special light bulb then there will be
what we see is outgoing one but of
course there's light also travels inside
and that that is just the ingoing one
that goes close to it
so
the interesting thing here is that
on the other side of the singularity
both light fronts are expanding out
and so it is called anti-tract region
in popular terms
the
the contracting region is called
the black hole type of region and this
is called the white hole type of ring
and that's why some people like to like
carlos for example i have to think about
as as a transition from
white hole from black hole to vital
i don't like that terminology because
that has because both black holes and
white holes have connotations of
there being a singularity somewhere
and there is no singularity here uh it
is just a trapped region where all the
light fronts are contracting and
anti-trapped regions where they are all
so i think we understand
fair amount of what is happening
but
if you want to know
much more
in detail about what happens in the
black hole operation
that subject is still under
investigation like in every other
approach up here
uh if i have time i just let me just say
mention one thing one is that because
it's often mentioned by people as being
a real problem
real paradox
so as you know supposing i have black
hole which is farthest and somehow
sending some bacteria this universe is
only there's nothing else in the
universe i ignore everything else and i
send in some matter and it forms a black
form supposing it forms a black full of
one soda mass
and then after that nothing is falling
into it from outside
then in classical generality the black
hole will just stay there it's going to
be one solar mass it'll just stay here
but because of hawking effect because of
quantum tunneling it is shrinking
and it is shrinking and shrinking and
shrinking and shrinking and becoming
smaller right and while it does it's
everything is gone
and this contour going up to infinity
and the big question is really the
following that
this outgoing quanta
look like
they're in a thermal state which is a
mixed state
it's not a pure state although why is it
not a pure state because these particles
this quant are created in pairs
one particle goes out to infinity and
its partner particle falls into the into
the black hole again
now if it falls in the black hole the
two are correlated
and therefore you're losing correlation
if you just look at infinity you're not
seeing what is happening inside so
you're losing correlations and that is
why you've got a mixed state again okay
so it's just like an ordinary quantum
mechanics except that is happening in
black holes if you're only seeing part
of the system and therefore just as an
aside for people the difference between
pure and mixed is
so a pure state is represented by kind
of
uh
by a bio wave function if you like right
it means or by by a element of a hilbert
space either a vector or a ray nearby
space
whereas a mixed state is represented by
a itself state itself is a manner
operator
so basically it is like
an operator in which i got just
say for example if i just have spin up
and spin down
then i'm going to have a
brow which is spin up bra which is spin
up and then some probability density
plus bra which is spin down bonus on
some probability density
or
rather spin up swing down spin down spin
up and some probability densities up
here so it is a it is a state which you
cannot write as just a
straightforward
or straightforward function
and it is sort of
basically saying that
the state has kind of two subsystems
and one is and they're correlated yeah
and if i now only look at one of the
subsystems outside of the subsystem
then technically what one has to do is
to trace over
this the states the subsystem that you
are not looking at and when you take
this trace of that it becomes a
density matrix or an operator because
you're taking a trace of it and you're
not
you're forgetting part of the
information
so i think that it's the simplest thing
is to say that you forget part
information
let me see if i can restate that so most
of the time when one is studying quantum
mechanics we hear about the wave
function but technically the wave
function is for pure states and even
that it's not a unique member because
you can take it it should be a project a
member of a projective space and then
most of the time we're we're dealing
with our ignorance we're dealing with
mixed states
which are operators which are matrices
instead of just a vector so what i want
to know is with these density operators
i believe they're called denser density
operators as well or is that false yeah
but i think it's much better but there's
more
i don't know the history but
there's a quantum mechanics that are
called whatever it doesn't matter so
with these mixed states do they arise
only from our ignorance from looking on
the outside and coarse graining or is
there is there something inherent about
the system that makes it mixed in some
way
right no i think that's in the context
of quantum mechanics it is in the
context of blackfall evaporation it is
our ignorance that but is fundamentally
ignorance because other particles got
inside the black hole
so inside the horizon and so that's a
phenomenal like that's okay but i mean
you could consider yeah please
okay so and then one on the outside of
the black hole there's these virtual
pairs and then one of them happens to go
inside and the other one escapes
so then does that mean equal amounts of
matter and anti-matter are coming out of
the black hole
yeah and is that okay that somehow
doesn't violate some law because matter
is what fell in but then sometimes
anti-matter is what comes out
yeah so the statement is that um
if for example you've got a charged
black hole then they'll be
preferentially
the preference of
charging negative then there'll be more
negative particles will come out but
also positive
charge particles will also come out come
now the black hole is drinking and we
understand so the black hole is
shrinking up here and then the statement
is that um
we're looking at uh
yeah and then and so
as a result of it
more and more
thermal radiation is going out to
infinity in other words
the whole state is a pure state because
you started with the pure state but what
is registered in infinity is only part
of the state and therefore we're not
looking at what is inside and therefore
it is actually
uh
the state which at infinity that we are
looking at
quote unquote appears to be mixed
and now
the point is that
this has
in my view given rise to some confusion
in the literature quite some confusion
in literature
because people take this event horizon
as being absolute
and it is true in classical general
activity
but
even in classical general relativity
there are things called dynamical
horizons
you see the event horizons are absolute
but they're also very
not directly physical in this following
sense
you know an event horizon might be
forming in the room that you're sitting
in right now it's completely contained
in the room that you're sitting right
now
and growing
the reason is because it's still
stereological
this is in response to what may happen a
billion years from today
that there may be a
collapse of in the gov
in the center of a galaxy somehow
credible
and then there will be huge black hole
and if i trace back the event horizon i
have to trace back the event i don't
know where it is until space time has
ended so to say i can trace back the
event horizon and then i'll find that oh
it was actually fine
there's a component in this room right
now i don't feel anything locally yeah
okay so event horizons are totally
logical they are not
people are used to event horizons only
in static situations like in the third
black hole or shawshank blackfall or
something they don't think too much
about the dynamical situations i mean
simplifying but i mean a lot of people
don't think enough
in the
in the dynamical situation that that's a
point and the dynamical situation the
statement is that event horizons like
what i'm saying about just now can can
be very
unphysical can be very ghost-like
but there are notions called
local quasi-local notions and like in
this room i can tell that there is no uh
cause of local horizons
that in fact i developed here
by postdocs and i developed these things
many years ago this was in the context
of um
privatization waves and black holes and
not but is now has been used
starting from them also in quantum
gravity because i was
working both those areas up here
and so if you take that more seriously
then in fact
there is isn't
such an absolute
end
there there's no there's no way for the
information to come out
that you have to couple with the fact
that
a loophole of gravity is singularity is
resolved
you see as long as there is
singularity then the kind of space-time
diagram that stephen hawking was drawing
initially he changed his mind later but
initially he was drawing
whichever end singularity of the black
hole the black horsing area even when
the black hole evaporates the space time
still has that singularity and then that
singularity can act as a sink of
information
and therefore you know if you therefore
it can happen that pure you start with a
pure state but you get a mixtape because
some information fell into that
singularity and it's completely
inaccessible
but if in fact singularity is resolved
and you don't have this absolute event
horizon
then this information can come out
at later times
and
there is no a priori problem about
the information coming out and this
metrics being united
now s matrix being unitary is not the
same as saying s matrix is identity we
are not saying that what comes out is
what goes in
people often i'm asking these questions
even in technical conferences by people
who are
outside quantum gravity but they say
well i don't understand i mean how can
it be that supposing i just take encyclo
britannica and i burn it
i lost information
so
this point is that no you're not lost
information
word information is funny but your lost
information in the sense that those
words that were written there
encyclopedia are lost but on the other
hand i had a state of the encyclopedia
and the fire and everything
and then i had a final state the final
state there's a lot of radiation that
came on something etcetera and both
those states are pure states ultimately
and because they have pure states i
could
information is not lost in the sense
that there's a unique transformation
which will bring me back i mean in
practice it is hopeless right
so so that is basically the statement up
here that there is no
you can have a very complicated i mean
when you smash particles in certain and
then you get something else and
obviously what you get out is completely
different from what you what you started
out with but information is not lost in
the sense that the s matrix is still
unit so that that's the point okay so i
think that you know s matrix i we
believe in look on gravity and most of
us believe in the kind of gravity is
unity
carlo and robelli and his group and i
and my postdoc so i've been working on
parallel lines
most of the time we have exactly we are
in agreement but we are not an agreement
on everything because there are open
issues that where you know we don't know
which way it is going to go and of
course with open issues you always have
prejudices about
what is likely to happen because that's
where you put more energy
and so there's there are differences but
another overall picture that i just
mentioned so far
is common to
many people working in lupon
so we believe the information is not not
really lost there's another issue that
is very interesting that
your audience might be quite interested
which is the following which is a
restricted form of information loss so
so let's not worry about singularity you
know i told you about singularity and
you know things can come out and people
might say well i don't know if
singularity is dissolved etcetera let's
not worry about it there is still a
problem quote unquote potential
at the early stages
so supposing i take a solo mass black
hole
and i let it evaporate till it becomes a
lunar mass
so it is about a millionth of its mass
now from whatever it is but still is the
microscopic object is the lunar mass
black hole up here right
so people have argued that even in this
process
some
classical considerations are not going
to be valid
and something drastic could happen and
these people were claiming things like
that means that even outside the event
horizon of astrophysical platforms
quantum effects would be important and
there would be
change of picture of understanding about
what is happening altogether
since ligo
data
which sort of
shows no surprises visibly classical
general relativity
these claims have been scaled back quite
a lot they are these ideas have been
scaled back for the long
that astrophysical black holes one would
be would encounter real problems that
has been scaled back quite a lot
but nonetheless people ask the following
question supposing i go from solar mass
to lunar mass
this process by the way is very slow yes
right takes you know 10 to the 76 yes
objects sure universe is only
a billion years so i mean 40 billion
years so this is huge compared to the
life history of the university
but still the statement is that what has
happened so during this 10 to 76 years
basically
the solar mass
has become millionth of a solar mass so
most of the solar mass right solar mass
minus a billionth of it has been
radiated away
and its partner modes are all in here so
there's a huge number of partner modes
if there's a huge amount of what sorry
a partner modes the modes which have
gone away the most of the
of the field like okay
the radiation which goes on people call
it modes also the field yeah so this
part these modes have gone away
uh gone to infinity and their partners
you might call them particles people
don't use the word particle because in
corner fields and curve space time the
motion of particle is not so sharply
defined so people talk about modes
rather than particles
but the statement is that this
there's more such particles that they're
gone away and their partners on the side
and so a huge number of correlations is
lost right because it's it's almost the
same as the mass of the sun right
muscles and minus
one minus one millionth
possible and so there's a huge number of
these moore's laws but by
now the
the radius of the horizon has shrunk
and how much has shrunk well it is i
shrunk as much as the schwarzschild
radius of a lunar mass black hole
how much is it roughly it is a
millimeter
so people say well wait a minute i got
this little thing with the millimeter
size thing right
and how can it hold so many boards
there's more the partner modes are all
here and there's just no way it can hold
all these all these little more so
and and then more sophisticated
arguments but that's the basic argument
up here and therefore there's something
some say my classical considerations
must go wrong
way before
the
solar bars black hole has shrunk don't
do the mass
that is argument
but then when we look at more detail
first of all not taking the event
horizon so seriously but looking at this
quasi-local horizons that i mentioned
before
and we look at the back reaction right
in other words
this this is over 10 to 76 years you
know almost the whole solar mass of
black hole so the mass of black hole
minus a millionth has fallen in it
so of course that is going to change the
geometry inside it's not going to be the
same geometry as before
and so
the question is what is happening to
this
geometry dynamically right you know how
is the change
and what we find is again this is done
independently by several people
the same conclusions
that what happens is that
if you look at a space like surface
constant time surface inside the horizon
of our black hole
so it is anchored on the horizon
uh and therefore it has a kind of a
two sphere here on the horizon right and
in a two-dimensional sphere up here and
then inside the it's like a tube right
it goes inside the space-like surface
looks like a tube up here
now in the beginning the tube has a
social radius of a solar mass black hole
so it's about a kilometer radius
and the length up here is also
kilometers roughly comparable i mean
it's not not much difference
but in this 10 to 76 years
the
the aperture of the black hole
the
portion from which it sort of
communicates with the outer world which
ends on this
positive local horizon
that shrinks and that i shrink to a
millimeter now
but what happened to this tube
amazingly this tube gets longer and
longer and longer and longer and longer
you say yeah but how much
well it gets longer like
10 to the
i don't know i forgot i should have
looked it before but
you know like 10 to the 80 light years
light years not not centimeters light
years so this tube is huge and long yes
and it's pinched too and and it's
pinched right exactly as it is
you know it's sort of it's finished and
it's like longer longer
and therefore you know this
what people call modes
which are inside the inside the inside
this tube the part in the board
like in inflation they get elongated
because this this thing was
small and then it's becoming longer
longer and longer so inside the modes
get elongated
as the geometry becomes longer and
longer the
the the
length proper length become and so they
become what people call infrared right
very very very low energy each of these
photons or you know each of these
particles if you want anything in the
particles or modes
is going to be very low energy
and therefore you can have lots of them
without any problem
and so the there's no paradox in that
sense because
if you take into account properly that
it's not an event horizon but it causes
local horizon and that these surfaces
you're taking into account the
background the the back reaction of the
geometry the geometry changes so much
that
it is perfectly fine to accommodate
a huge number of modes
even though the end point has only a
millimeter
sphere of millimeter
and therefore
you have
this huge amount of energy which is
almost a solar mass of energy
and huge number of moles of there
and um
uh
and there's no problem
so
so this this is a kind of a i mean it's
not a new idea i've been looking at
people i've been working on it for you
know
six seven eight years but a lot of
people don't realize that's relatively
new
yeah it's very interesting i think so so
already the semi-classical region where
solar mass black hole becomes a lunar
mass black hole it looks like there is
an apparent paradox but in fact if you
look at the
in the apparent paradoxes how can a
little thing like that hold so many more
and the point is that it's little thing
only vis-a-vis the outer world is
concerned it has internal structure
surface is an internal structure which
is huge we either used to call it bags
of gold
that you can have a little throat but a
huge bag of gold now it's not a
huge like that is more like a
tube is it the same volume is quite
large because of the even though the
surface area is small the wall will be
very large
okay now you just mentioned this word
outer world which we're going to get to
but how about we take a small break yeah
let's take a break
and then we'll get to we'll get to
salvador pius's question and then the
inner world
professor i have a question about adm
decomposition
where one assumes global hyperbolicity
to form a cauchy surface and so on and
i'm curious is that a reasonable
assumption that this can always be done
or does that reject a certain class of
solutions to general relative to
einstein's equations
yeah so it does have
i mean idm decomposition has to do with
the dividing sp
space time it is space and time
it's a three plus one decomposition
and
it breaks the manifest covariance of
general activity if you like uh but on
the other hand
if you look at this
the space of solutions are exactly the
same as the space absolution of general
relativity so it doesn't lose anything
from general relativity
except
if the space time is not globally
hyperbolic
i mean assume that space time is global
hyperbolic in other words it emits
approaching surface because it just is
based on the initial value formulation
there are solutions like golden universe
which are close time that occurs which
are excluded in the adm formulation
but most people don't consider this as
being a serious drawback of the radiant
formulation
and the global hyperbolicity condition
is that related at all to the
cosmological constant or no
no
no it's not it's not related to cosmos
so you could have
globally i mean most people most of the
space styles people use
in cosmology with the cosmological
constant are all global hyperbolic
there's no problem at all
um
but i mean you could also construct
non-globally hyperbolic space time with
a corresponding constant it's not very
difficult but
people think of global hyperbolicity as
a physically reasonable assumption
there's a widely it doesn't mean that
other things are totally
people should abolish space-time but
that's more exotic possibilities
so like there are close time-like curves
at least in girdle like there's a girl
universe which broadly universe has
close time like girls and so yeah
so when people say hey close time like
curves are you can't they're unphysical
well there's nothing about general
relativity that says you can't have
closed timeline curves correct
right so it is true that
that adm framework and
most of the things that people do you
know even classical general relativity
and they use the idiom framework very
heavily in numerical duty and so on so
forth
but there are versions of atm framework
but they use them very very much
they all assume global hyperbolicity you
know in the
black hole
ligo problems and numerical relativity
problems everywhere it is assumed to be
global hyperbolic and adm framework is
widely used so i don't think you lose
anything now the question is for
something like quantum gravity or
something like conceptual sculpture or
something
could you do something without the three
plus one decomposition
and in fact
uh the you you say you had such
send me some some
paper
uh and that paper just belong with
begins with the quotations by lagrange
and so on
and it turns out that
there was a lagrange
bicentennial i think uh which was uh
there was a special volume for that and
and i was asked to write an article
and
it is true that lagrange himself
actually suggested this very beautiful i
mean he led the seeds of it i should say
which is developed by other people like
all this very beautiful way of doing
things without any
decomposition into space and time uh
even particle mechanics the idea there
is the phase space is not x and p or x
and x dot at
any instant of time but the whole
solution dynamical solution it's like
the block in universes like it's a it's
a whole solution of the entire particle
trajectory is a point to the phase space
so it's called the covariant phase space
formulation
and
i used i mean i developed i developed
that for field theory um when i was
doing quantum physical space time in the
70s already
and then
i mean i taken these ideas and they were
not used until then as far as i know for
free theories
and then in the
uh
in the for this volume then i looked at
general relativity in the covariant
uh phase-based formulation which does
not use space-time time
they come with the space time in this
place and time and i showed that in fact
you do get
things like the adm hamiltonian and even
the so-called the
null at the in presence of gravitational
waves you have got so-called bondi
energy and bonding for momentum
just like you have got adm i don't know
if there's a mission of energy and a
three momentum you also have the same
quantities that
in presence of radiation
which actually decrease in time because
the gravitational waves
go away adm four momentum is conserved
because it includes everything
so we we recovered all those things
using covalent phase space formulation
without any three-person decomposition
so it's possible
and i was at time as sometimes quite
interested in thinking that whole
quantum theory could be done with the
covariant phase space
but then as time went on i realized that
no that's not really possible because
basically
what quantum theory it does for example
in quantum tunneling
is precisely allow certain effectiveness
allowing
trajectories which are not classically
allowed right they're classically
forbidden that something which is
alpha particle inside the nucleus can
actually come out
classically it could not do that
there is a probability that it comes out
but classically there is no dynamic or
tragedy classical the potential is such
that there is no dynamical trajectory
that will allow you for the alpha
particle classical dynamical trajectory
to
view the nucleus and come out i already
feel like you know
kind of mechanically there's a
probability that
a stone on the ground
could
spontaneously come and break my window
up here
it's a it's a very minor problem
um but but there's a probability that
that could happen or classically it
cannot happen there's no cluster
dynamically
there's a kinematical trajectory
so that's why
feynman developed this some more
histories approach in which he allowed
kinematical trajectories which are not
necessarily dynamic for those interested
in hearing more about the girdle
universe visit the link in the
description as some physicists have
animated it as well as they give more of
an explanation as to what the girdle
metric is and its consequences
so the point is that all of quantum
physics cannot be captured by if you
restrict yourself from the beginning
to the space of classical solutions
and the covariant phase space
is the space of classical solutions it
is isomorphic with the standard face
space which is x and p phase space
because if you give me an x and p i get
a unique dynamic trajectory
so the covariance phase space is like
the canonical state i mean
mathematically it's equivalent or
something but as far as quantum theory
is concerned
i i feel that i do i still today feel
that
it's not possible to use
based on the quantum
theory
uh starting with the classical uh point
of departure being the covariant uh
phase space i think you have to use
if you want to use a phase space you you
do need to use a canonical phase space
then you have these wave functions of x
only they are not very function of
classical trajectories space of
classical directions up here
and so i think that there is
classical you can avoid three plus one
splitting
you can't consider the four way in face
space
it's not very useful for quantization i
believe
did i answer the question
yeah yeah and i'll briefly you mentioned
okay for people who are wondering what's
the context what the heck is this paper
i refer to well
adm decomposition is extremely important
in loop quantum gravity and other
approaches and then on the wikipedia
page there was some controversy that
perhaps adm decomposition is not always
allowed or not always admissible and so
i was asking professor astrocar what is
his opinion on this and can you take a
look at this paper so that's what that
was about okay now you also mentioned
finance some overall paths and as far as
i know in loop quantum gravity there's a
there's something similar where we sum
over graphs but it's not like we sum
over all possible graphs
so if you place some conditions on the
graphs and i'm curious so are those
conditions you feel like justified or
eventually you want to get to some
approach where you some over quote
unquote all graphs
no use some are all kinematically
kinematically possible gloves but the
difference in lupine gravity is that
which is conceptually quite an
interesting difference that one is not
looking at
something or classical trajectories
in other words
because the classical trajectories would
be this is important classical
trajectories would be classical food
geometries
all possible classical four geometries
here what one is doing is one is
summing over
trajectories which are in contemporary
money in geometry
right from the beginning so they are not
smooth metrics
but these two complexes with uh put some
data on them and colors two complexes as
one says it
but it is all possible i mean
goal is all possible in practice of
course you know you do approximations
just like what one does in corner field
theory in
in
any way so therefore i start completely
right to say that in loop on gravity one
uses adm
framework starts with it's true that
some people do that but it's not
necessary after the adm frame but
particularly in spin forms but even in
canonical picture right and people
you can say adm like frame but which in
which they do three plus one
decomposition so that is fair that
because
what people use is the is the framework
that i gave and then people modify it
right which is based on connections and
not metrics it's not the idiom frame
let's get to salvador pius's question
which i sent you a large pdf about which
actually he sent me so i'm going to
put that in the description for people
if they'd like to look at and as for the
question itself i'll quote from sal who
says
professor ashtakar what do you think of
salvator pious idea of the super force
quote unquote does it exist at the
ashtakar bounce critical point
okay
so
the
i mean i did go through what you have
sent me um
this super force is supposed to be given
by i think
newton's constant divided by some power
of the speed of light so that the
dimensions are the dimensions of force
of fluid
there is no hbar in it at all
but it is claimed that some at least in
the couple of pages that you sent me it
was claimed that somehow it is
unification of all forces and these
super forces arising from there and so
on
i mean i don't see how it's a completely
classical idea and i don't see how
it can be it can incorporate a weak
interaction strong interactions which
are quintessentially
quantum mechanical and even
electromagnetic interaction because
electro weak go hand in hand together
because of unification
so i i mean
i don't see how this super force can be
anything like fundamental in any sense
uh as far as the quantum bounce is
concerned
it is true that
i mean as i was saying before i was
myself surprised that
for the longest time
uh until you know the density becomes
or ten thousands of plant density
uh
classical picture is perfectly fine and
then suddenly
this new quantum effects take into
picture
and
in heuristic terms one often says that
gravitational force is normally
attractive
but then
suddenly this quantum effect becomes
the quantum connections become they are
always repulsive but that is successful
and they suddenly dominate in this plank
regime and then overwhelm the classical
gravitational attraction that's what
people say that that's what i say or
other people say i i should say that
this is it's one of those things in
which people in physics
literature i mean
advanced people or graduate students
they understand what i want what it is
meant i mean there is no such thing as
gravitational force
already in classical general activity
right i mean it's manifestation
but this is a way of just
shorthand way of talking about
about the bounds
so i just want to make sure that that is
also true that there is force is not a
fundamental concept either in classical
generality or in
or in chronic knowledge
what we have is
like ranges and donuts and propagators
and so on
and also when a physicist uses the word
force now at least in high energy they
generally mean interactions
they don't mean
f equals m a yeah exactly right exactly
but i think that the word force should
not be used because this terribly
confuses people
agree but another hand is just in
english language to say that well
well it
this classical interaction dominates for
a long time and then quantum interaction
just takes over it just doesn't
communicate
that's a shorthand but it's it's not
it's just a shot at it
now briefly before we get to string
theory and the comparison between loop
and string
loop qg in string
talking about the big bang we didn't get
to what occurred before the big bang
so it depends on basically what one is
doing in all these models is when it's
starting at a given instant time as i
said i mean the post big bang in our
branch of the universe whether you do us
away from a plank regime so that you can
trust classical general relativity
take a wave function which is sharply
peaked and then you're valuing it back
so if in fact in this post big bang
picture what you have is a
is is a classical solution that your
wave function is peaked at
is
the uh
especially flat
friedman
robertson walker universe
then what happens is that after the
bounce
it joins on to another
especially flat uh universe just goes
back it's not necessarily symmetric it
depends on the initial state up here
it's not the time symmetry of always i
mean it can be time symmetric but it
doesn't have to be time symmetry depends
on the state that you have chosen up
here which because the the many sharply
peak states that people choose okay
but still it's basically on the other
side there's another large
especially flat universe
if another and and also if you started
out with what is called
open universes where there's a spatial
curvature it's not spatially flat
but the
spatial curve which is negative
then in the open universes it turns out
that
there's again a branch which is
you know
in the past like in the specially flat
case but if you started out with the
what is called space positively curved
uh spaces
space sections which is going to be a
three sphere
so topology is that of a three
dimensional sphere instead of our
three dimension r3 instead of euclidean
space
then
you get
classical relativity says that while you
start at the big bang the universe will
actually expand out and then there will
be a re-collapse and there is a big
crunch of it so in this case what
happens if you started the big bam i
mean the general relativity says that so
now here if you start in the middle and
you go back
then again you get a universe which is
again specially closed so again three
sphere topology goes on the other side
but then that universe is going to go
and then there's going to be a big
current singularity
classically but quantum mechanical is a
big bounce so there are there is
infinite sequence of these big bounces
oh there's an infinite sequence of them
okay so let me just restate this because
i want to make sure that the profundity
of this isn't lost so if we rewind our
universe back we get to the big bang and
then the claim here is that a
possibility is that
prior to the big bang was another
universe that from its perspective was
crunching to a big bang which produced
ours because there's this bounce that
occurs once you get to what's what we
think of as the singularity
okay then that's under the loop quantum
cosmology model
okay so from my understanding prior to
10 seconds ago
it was this is our universe we're going
back to the big bang and then we think
well this could have started from the
crunch of another universe so let's
imagine that let's imagine it did but
then i was wondering well loop quantum
cosmology says nothing about this other
universe where did it come from does it
just expand forever in that direction
now you're saying that oh no actually it
it could we could have infinite cycles
you know it depends on the apology
no it depends on your assumption it's
not it's look on cosmology are just like
generality it doesn't have a specific
prediction you have to tell me the
matter content of the universe
so so
if the
classical general relativity you have
um what is called critical matter
density
if the matter density in the universe is
less than some amount
then the universe would be
what they call specially open
if it is exactly the critical density
then it is specially flat
and if it is bigger than the special the
critical value then it is closed
universe okay
so
classical generality also doesn't it's
an observational question
and so but these are the possibilities
and what i outlined was what happens in
the three possibilities in loop quantum
cosmology
in the three three possibilities
in the
the possibility where
the matter density is less than or equal
to the critical density you just have
one bounce
and then the statement is that yeah
there are the universe which is uh of
pre-pre-bounced bang and there's a lot
of ideas about i mean calculations about
what was the nature of that universe etc
but maybe that's that's going too far
we'll have another discussion because of
we have so many physics questions but
there we also want to get to some
questions regarding consciousness so one
so the statement up here is that it
really depends on the special topology
the special topology were closed but
then i should just add that one guys oh
but then we know something about our
universe today so what is a
which one is it
so it looks that overwhelmingly that is
specially
flat it's not it's not it's not closed
universe i mean it's not there's always
going to be some error in observation
error but it is supposed to be i mean
there's all there's a general
picture people use is that especially
so so in that case there is there is not
multiple
bounces yeah please go ahead sure let's
compare string to loop
oh okay
um
yeah
so string theory started with particle
physics
uh kind of emphasis and loop quantum
gravity started with the general treaty
emphasis so from the beginning you know
the ideas were different
particle physics was emphasizing field
theoretical methods in in the beginning
was perturbative methods
um
but over the time
they also started giving up
paying more attention to the
non-productivity methods and now
much work is done in non-particular
methods particularly with this adf cft
formulation
so in that sense i mean that
conceptually philosophically they're
coming together and also the importance
of background independence is something
that is more and more appreciated as as
distinct theory went further and further
away from the productivity methods this
was more and more appreciated
the
difference is based still the difference
namely that in string theory there isn't
so much because it of its origin
particle physics
there is so much emphasis on unification
of all interactions whereas loop quantum
gravity it's not that people are not it
interested of course they're very
interested but the main goal is not
unification of all interactions the main
goal is really quantum nature of
geometry now one might say well you
could never understand quantum geometry
until you bring in all interactions that
may be the case
but
what we have seen is that
we could actually understand
electromagnetic
interaction by itself then it was
unified with electro weak interaction
and
then you know people at some stage
thought that
really to understand strong interactions
you need to grind unified field theory
in which one gut in which you've got
all
that all three electromagnetic weak and
strong interactions together people
tried that for a long time they even had
a prediction that proton should decay
the proton doesn't decay and if since
4000 decay i think that idea is sort of
fitted out
that that should be the only way to do
things and people are just looking at
qcd by itself
and huge success looking at qcd by
itself so i don't see why looking at
gravity and looking at the fundamental
conceptual issues that are posed by
gravity which are unique because the
theory of space-time structure
is not going to teach us huge amount of
things more i mean it has already taught
us in classical relativity you know
completely new physics right
gravitational waves
big bang and black holes so the question
is i mean we can look for this
qualitatively new things
like what happens
before the big bang what happens to the
black holes black hole evaporation is
also and that's what we're doing
now because of this
i think partly because of this emphasis
on unification
in string theory
there are all kinds of elements that
were brought in
first was super symmetry
second was
higher dimensions
and then there was positive uh the
negative cosmology constant
and the point was that because you
brought in super symmetry and
then you looked at the
natural ground state and
there was a negative smaller constant
and so on and you know there are
conferences in string theory when people
when first the idea
came up that in fact the cosmological
constant is positive and some
preliminary evidence came up the
conference in which very prime
ministering series
series on record has said that it can't
be it will go away i mean it's
completely wrong because
because we know from super symmetry that
it must be negative and it's not
negative you know it is positive
so there are these ingredients
i mean if these are not optional things
in string theory they lie at the
foundation of string theory higher
dimensions super symmetry
and
and the negative cosmetic constant none
of which are seen in
nature
the people are trying hard looking for
this and that now it doesn't mean that
tomorrow people won't find it but i i
should emphasize that even if they were
to find super symmetry it doesn't mean
string theory is right right there's
just specific there may be meditating
symmetric theory so the case is not
strong in terms of what observations are
telling us today
and i don't think that string theory has
given us
reliable insights or
good physical insights are on which one
can build on for future work about the
nature of singularities or even about
black folk evaporation today
there have been a lot of
very bold ideas
uh but you know it's one of those things
this board ideas are put forward there's
a rush of my papers incredible i mean
that was first
you know various people in stanford were
talking about quantum xerox machines
in order to talk about black hole
information that modes which go out to
infinity information that goes out
infinity somehow
xerox somehow duplicated near the
surface near the horizon of course
they're taking event verizon as being
absolute and somehow that's why you can
get unitarily that's a repeated out then
there was a quest
no that was prior to idea of safety
that was actually present and then there
was of course the idea cft
and radio safety again is something that
is done in
negative cosmology i mean one doesn't
really know much at all about even zero
cosmologist or positive cosmos constant
universes
and so i think you know
someone gets the impression that
a lot of effort is being
put in areas where one can actually
get
good mathematical results
solid mathematics
so whether it has much to do with our
actual viewers or not is seem to be
secondary concentration perhaps this is
driven by the idea that well just
because we don't know much about the
universe and if not natural theory is
found then
the universe will obey it you know that
said that about the cosmological
constant they have said that about
supersymmetry people are given even
skills that which should be found
because they're natural and they're not
and there are examples in physics where
very prominent people have talked about
talked about some natural ideas
i mean one of the things that people
don't
know very much about is the following
you know
just in the end of 1800s
very prominent people including lord
kelvin
uh
had really thought that
what are atoms because people are
realizing their atoms and there are
discrete spectral lines people i just
realized that
and their idea was that atoms are really
vortices in ether because they believe
in ether
and atoms are vertices meter and now
what is it so they thought well hydrogen
atom seems to be the simplest atom
so it's a it's a circle
it's
a circle
then if you have a next atom that you
know was
the helium atom and the helium atom they
thought was a trophy not
it's one of those things this isn't it's
not in the north theory it was simplest
beautiful not people use that those nuts
and on the boards and things like that
so there's a trophy not and then more
and more complex atoms would become more
and more complicated knotted
structures of ether so there are ether
some lines in ether which are bent and
which are knotted together and they
become the atoms and these knots are
vibrating
and that's why we see the spectrum and
these are very prominent people we were
saying that i mean i just gave you an
extremely creative idea
i'm wondering how the heck do you come
up with that absolutely crazy
they thought that and then they
convinced a scottish mathematician tate
to think about knox
not theory was not
yeah uh-huh and not theory was born out
of this
ah i didn't know that the whole thing
started because they thought that
that atoms are not in ether
interesting that's how it started it's a
beautiful mathematical idea beautiful
bold idea they talked about variety they
talked about how discreetness might come
because of this you know vibrational
modes because the close thing
i think our vibrational modes are
quantized and that might explain that
atomic structure
and michael atiyah who was a very famous
mathematician has a very nice little
book on this and the origin of mark
theory and how it came about very very
small book um
so
the
so these things have happened you know
then there was another
big thing from my community john wheeler
and john wheeler
was a very imaginative person and
everything
and he thought that elementary particles
were chemistry of geometry it's a little
like this idea if you like
but now
not the atomic level but at the level of
elementary particles
and again he thought that there was some
general relativity there were some
structures which are purely
gravitational some complicated so it's
not now one dimensional but more
complicated structures which are called
geons
topologically built in such things how
do you spell that
juan's
g-e-o-n-s
g-e-o-n
right
and and he had you know you
said he talked about elementary
particles chemistry of geometry
i may be misremembering but i think
there's even a large chapter of the
textbook gravitation of mr conveyor
might have a chapter on this uh might
have section on the chemistry of
geometry
which is this idea again it's a very you
know very beautiful idea that that
everything after all is just geometry
that you know that this all comes from
excitation of geometry that
topological excitations and all
elementary particles are just that's
what happened i have clever idea it did
not work
uh i i mean i can go on and there's a
whole one steady state universe i
already mentioned people were very
imaginative very leading physicists said
about
it
so i think that just because
some mathematical structures look very
natural and nice
i don't and there is enough precedent
that that doesn't imply that they have
anything to do with our actual physical
world and it would be good for us to
keep that in mind i mean it may have but
this confidence and
you know i have to quote alan greenspan
was a
uh the head of the federal reserve you
know you called about exube
something exuberant right an unrest
unfettered exuberance
that i think is not necessary i mean we
we can be we can have bold ideas we can
put forward them but to take the
viewpoint that that is the only solution
is not something that is that is really
called
and so now the question is what is
happening today
how do how do string theory and loop on
gravity or any other approach
where are we today about it
so there is a very nice article
um on on the web page of
the institute for advanced study
by somebody who was a journalist in
residence there
about you know the current status of
string theory and the abstract and the
title of the abstract actually say
explicitly that string theory has not
lived up to its promise of
unifying general relativity and
common physics
but it has a
remarkable second
the title is second life upstream theory
it has a remarkable second life as
as a
extremely
rich toolbox for all branches of physics
yes yes you don't see that to be the
case or no no i i do see that to be the
case i agree with that
so but it does evolve in that direction
right and in the sense of you know very
very
clever things that they can do even for
mathematics that sort of made you know
uh very beautiful things in algebra
geometry
um mirror symmetry
i mean there are symmetry then that
there is the whole idea about the
uh superconductivity you know condensed
matter in other words strongly
correlated systems being
they did not know how to find these
functions for them in condensed
metaphysics but then they use this idea
about some kind of a duality and
therefore they could calculate it in the
weak field
in the weak uh coupling constant limit
in
gravity and then they could calculate
those functions so these are extremely
rich toolbox and i think you know
it's something
great to have that toolbox up here but
toolbox is very different from
theory of everything
as it is
and i think that you know that
they're admitting i mean the leading
leading string theories were quoted in
this article and uh
they're admitting that you know yes i
mean it's not really that but it's it's
just a second rebirth and therefore it's
going to remain
and i have no
no qualms about him i think i agree it
is a very rich toolbox
but i think
toolbox is not a
it's not a fun theory
of physics it does not
which with which you can probe nature in
many many ways now what would the string
theorists say to you they're like okay
you say this about us but uh hey all the
loop people
yeah so i don't know i mean it depends
on
which string tv
okay let's pick david gross
oh david gross is an open openly said
somewhere right that it is [ __ ] so i
think that is
difficult
okay so that's what he would say okay so
let's pick someone who has a bit more of
a specific criticism but i mean it's
somebody like gary horowicz i mean he
he has told me several times trying to
get gary is one who was
worked because he also began in general
activity so we can speak the similar
language but until
when was it until
2008 and nine
every year i i used to write notes on
what progress and my main things in
string theory and i used to
keep a in a notebook and everything so
you know i used to talk with gary and
find out you know various things so
one of my former post docs don merov is
a
senior figure in string theory and also
in santa barbara so you know we talk and
so
don had done some early work into
gravity so he knows that subject as well
and when we talk about an open
disagreement
when we talk we you know we
they're much more to me it is much more
reasonable in the sense of
there's no irrational exuberance that
was a framework that the frame the
phrase that
um there is much more you know yeah this
is work but you know we believe that
this is pointing direction in this
particular way and we're excited about
this and i said yeah and that's that's
good i mean you know this is an
interesting idea
i would tell them what they're doing
they say yeah i mean this these these
guys can
resolve singularities and that's a good
thing so that's string theories like
that who i i no problem that you know
about i mean when we are nobody else
it's a regular scientific discussion
it's not kind of political politics
but that there are enough i mean so
that's good that there aren't enough of
them
we can have this discussion we are far
from having the finals so if luke and
can play a claim that we're very close i
i don't i wouldn't agree with them
either on the other hand i do think that
some basic ideas of gluconeography such
as quantum nature of geometry are going
to stay
that's that's what i want
here's a quick statement from edwitton
and this comes from the book
conversations on quantum gravity
the interviewer says due to the lack of
experimental data there exists a
plethora of different approaches to
quantizing gravity which of these
approaches in your opinion is closer to
a true description of nature and why
then edwin said this i think your
premise is misleading string theory is
the only idea about quantum gravity with
any substance
one sign is that where critics have had
an interesting idea so non-commutative
geometry black hole entropy twister
theory they have been
they tended to be absorbed as a part of
string theory
another sign is that
well okay we'll end it right there okay
so what are your comments on that
um
yeah i don't know if i want to say names
i was just debating about that um
i'm adding
everybody is entitled to their opinion
and i i just have kind of two remarks
you know sure
there is a remark that i liked very much
by
richard feynman
and
the remark says that
you should have a reality check and so
he says
it doesn't matter how beautiful your
idea is
it doesn't matter what your name is
if your theory is not realized in nature
it is wrong
and i kind of feel that one should keep
that in mind that that's my first remark
at that very nice comment of richard
finance and the second is
that
there was this conference
which was 25th anniversary of
kitp
you know
and that you know that invited some
people that happened to be invited me as
a representative on gravity i suppose um
and there
there's a
prominent
um
sing theories
or or kind of a tea break or coffee
break
who were chatting and he said
he repeated to me what you just read
ah this is a while ago at which
by far the number one
computer company or the company in the
world financial institution was
microsoft so he said well
you know
string theory is like microsoft
and
what microsoft does has done
successfully is that any time there is a
competition or something they have
successfully incorporated that
in them so it becomes part of microscope
and he said
he was nice very nice but he said
the same thing is
true uh with string theory
that we have incorporated matrix model
where intel current and formal field
theory and we can interpret and
non-committed geometry
on the other hand he says
look quantum gravity is the one thing
that we're not incorporated and look
quantum drive is like apples
and at that time i didn't say anything
it's like apples
like apple apple oh like apple computer
oh okay yeah as opposed to microscope
yes yes yes
and so i think
to me this conversation was very
illuminating yeah about
the that you know success being
microsoft and
that was a model of success at the time
of microsoft incorporating everything
together
and apple didn't do that
and where we are today where we are so
i think people can
take uh
take their
judgment about
the value of such yeah you know i was
reading this book from lisa mullen i
don't recall which one one of the he has
written many books maybe it was rhodes
to quantum gravity he said that there
was a principle of duality which is
extremely vaguely named because there
are many principles of duality in
physics and mathematics so i had no idea
i couldn't find a reference to this
i emailed him and i said what are you
referring to and then he wasn't he can
get back to me but he said in the book
that there's this principle of duality
that a statement in loop quantum gravity
becomes a statement in string theory and
vice versa or that he conjectures that
there's one because there seems to be
some for a certain class of questions i
didn't find any more information other
than that
and
either way lee seems to think that both
loop and string are somehow
approximations of some other real theory
rather than it seems like you're on the
more you're on the approach that well
firstly loop is not claiming to be a toe
to be a grand unified theory it's a
quantum theory of geometry which is
quote-unquote quantum theory of gravity
okay so firstly there's that
and so it sounds a bit more like you're
you have a tempered view of loop quantum
gravity and lee has a more expansive
view that incorporates both
where do you agree and disagree and do
you have any references for me to look
up this principle of duality because i
it was i'm still
i'm still looking to read something
concrete about it
well i
i mean i don't have a good recollection
of dates uh about when lee might have
said that
but
i mean there are instances right i mean
for example
when we're talking about
you know this work on black hole entropy
that i've done with john buys and killed
the crutches now
in that work
again somehow this idea about punctured
spheres was playing a big role and again
the gauge series and
uh and
and then if you look at the
the string theory idea that their brain
and then there were
there are also punctures on the brain
that were made by
by strings
and then
and so at one stage i mean
we we thought that there was actually
some relation
it is also true that you know if you
take
lee and carlo and i wrote a paper which
is called gravitons and loops in which
we
these are
linearized gravitons so in gasket space
we we formulated the theory in terms of
kind of thickened loops
we introduced a notion of the form
factor of the loop and such thing
and the point was that if you just
start with completely in the beginning
then you find that there is a graviton
there is an anti-symmetric tensor there
is a dilator
and that's what people found in bosonic
strings
and so that does it look like in the
early days that they may be
saying similar things in different
worlds and it still might be that some
of the things are similar but i think
my view is that
the way that the things are developed
since then both both in the quantum
gravity and string theory
[Music]
photography in in loop on gravity and so
on so forth
i don't think that string theory people
take it very seriously
so i don't know
where it is going to go to go you know
where it's going to go and so
so that what i'm saying is that in the
in the initial stage this duality that
lee was talking about might have been
about just a couple of examples i gave
there's some
idea that
that same kind of concepts appear in
both approaches
but i think that
is to over time
disrupt more and more such
connections
there have been less and less such
connections
professor
i'm sure you're aware and carla revellis
brought this up the physicists of the
past were extremely philosophical and
then now there's this excoriation of
philosophy in academy where it's seen as
that's ill-defined that's superstitious
in some manner and it's going to lead
you off the deep end even though
as you outlined well many of the
physicists aren't attached particularly
to reality with their musings
mathematically do you think that
this is true physicists have lost their
way is it a negative or a positive in
terms of abandoning philosophy
the physicists should be more
philosophical
from
i think there's been a branching of ways
but it's not something that is most
recent so
if i went go back in time right i mean
lot of time
philosophy was often natural philosophy
right i mean if you look at
socrates and plato and
on the indian philosophy side or
something like brahmagupta was a strong
number and they were interested in the
natural world and they're also
interested in philosophy yes
this and in fact
a lot of philosophy was philosophy of
natural philosophy which is
then sometime i think
around the time of galileo and kepler
and newton
we had a branching a little bit namely
science i mean in some sense this
natural philosophy was too successful in
that in bred science
particularly physics and astronomy
and so
somehow
science i mean for this long time has
actually
taken over
that side of philosophy
i mean there is a very beautiful book by
the father and son team
which is called
the philosopher and the monk
and the philosopher
the french and the philosopher is um
franz farabel that is his pen name
uh
philosopher and the monk
a philosopher in the monk and france
or the father was a philosopher he was a
real figure in
in france and very influential figure in
france
he
he was very strongly in first of all
against the catholic church and then he
was also anti-communist which someone
made him left him in no man's land
okay
uh and his son matt curica who actually
started as a neuroscientist and he
got his phd with
one of the nobel laureates and paris i
forget another name
that a couple of them started i'll get
them mixed up and then at a postdoc
opportunity as opposed to go to
stanford he had the offer of yours he
was ready to go
but in the meanwhile he had also met
some buddhist monks
and had gone to india and so on and so
and due to his father's horror he
actually
relinquished
science and went into became a buddhist
monk and he is the dalai lama's chief
french translator
you find him every many places sometimes
he's called the happiest man etc etc
that's not important the important thing
is that maurice ravel has sort of said
it's just this nice account of you know
how philosophy has developed and not
developed and so on so forth
that sometime around that you know
around the galileo newton
um
somehow philosophy lost this
natural philosophy to
science
and
it also had wisdom
you know you
that wisdom aspect somehow
was stolen by more religious traditions
and so
he is i mean himself as a philosopher
but he sort of felt that well somehow
the field
has gotten dilute because of you know
in some ways
other branches grew much more
and i i mean i kind of
i'm quoting him because i
i feel that there is some
large grain of truth in this
so if you look at for example
uh the
beginning of 20th century right i mean
there's a other important lecture by
max planck
who says
philosophers of today sit in physics
departments
and he says that their names are albert
einstein and niels bohr
so there are there was this going in
that direction right some other threats
so so i think that this has really has
happened and i know that
really in 1930s there were
philosophers in oxford and it's not a
little place or something
we're arguing that on philosophical
grounds special productivity could
possibly not be right
and so there has been and so i'm just
saying these things because these things
have somehow led to a deep mistrust
in a lot of physics communities
about
you know utility and
usefulness
of philosophy and philosophy of science
as well
however i find personally that
there is a general new generation a
newer generation not so new because
there are 10 year professors now and so
on but of of philosophers of science who
actually understand
the
the physics and mathematics that is
needed and that is always a problem
right and you need so much
mathematical background to understand
what physical concepts are and then to
be able to evaluate them otherwise you
are always
years and years behind
um
but there isn't
that few they're not
you can probably
maybe 20 years so that i want to know
less than 20 uh who
who actually are able to do this i think
that those people
can contribute
greatly
i mean i think they should be taken more
seriously than my business community
than they are
so i i i kind of feel that
physics has become very specific and
very technical and so on so forth so it
is true that
that this is just dismissed philosophy
altogether i
i think that it's too harsh and true and
called for stand
but on the other hand uh i think it's
also true that
a lot of
philosophy people don't really know
science and it just become difficult
just because of this specialization
but i think that
that with this young generation there is
a hope and useful things that can be
useful
can you give me an example perhaps a
concrete example or a specific one where
someone of our generation was able to
merge philosophy and physics
and
contribute something that perhaps just
soul physics couldn't do
when i say soul physics i mean s-o-l-e
without the soul of the s-o-u-l
yeah that that people from
that i happen to know from the
pittsburgh school of philosophy of
science
who for example
have worked on things like um
the time reversal in variance
and
they underst and they're formulated
the way that time reversal is is
actually analyzed in physics communities
and so on stuff
and
one of them
actually
yeah i don't want to go into too many
details because i
various names of principles and so on
because they're not going to explain too
much of that
but they formulated the ways that
they sort of codified thoughts if you
like
by saying that well
this is a way of looking at time
the magnetics this is another way of
looking at time reversal success
research
and
they
for example
pointed out that
maybe
there are more general ways of looking
at time reversal universal invariants
and there is i think in part because
people in pittsburgh where
because gravity group is from there
carlo was there for a while a long time
ago and so on so the gravitational group
is strong there and so they are familiar
with
some of the
topics that
the forefront topics in physics so they
are very aware in quantum gravity and so
you know they were raising questions
such as
what would happen in quantum gravity
because many of the things that one uses
to talk about time reversal in variance
are so deeply rooted in pancreatic group
and
so the question is well
gravity and everything and particularly
arguments will foreign go through
and uh and unitary and unitary operators
and
s matrices and etcetera etcetera
so i think that that was quite
quite insightful so that is an example
in which
they
they were able to formulate
um
the
they were able to kind of classify the
effects that the the
the arguments that physicists have made
into categories and then from those
categories
say that well
if you wanted to generalize physics
further and include quantum gravity
then one would have to rethink about
time reversal values i thought that was
quite uh
quite insightful
and i actually
it led me to think about time reversal
quite a bit
and
realizing that in fact you don't need
much of the machinery that is a new
usually used to talk about time reversal
in quantum mechanics and um
so i i know that
there are things like that they're not
i don't want to give
many many i mean i don't want to say
that there are you know dozens of such
examples but there are examples
sorry is time reversal distinct from
time travel
yeah
so time it was
there so i mean they clarified you know
that
there's a
the the question is about time reversal
and basic laws of physics i mean because
people also say that about something
like entropy increasing means that you
know you don't have time reversal i mean
people say that well
the glass fell down and it was broke and
then it's not it's not spontaneous but
but the point is that that's not true
right because if i just
took the final state and reversed all
the in classical mechanics and reverse
all the velocity they should actually
come
come back
i mean the point is that those initial
conditions
form such as tiny fraction of the whole
face space that is very unlikely
and so that very very cleanly
distinguished distinction they made the
clean distinction between
that's not
what they were talking about they were
talking about time reverse in the
fundamental laws of physics
and and that's what is true with respect
to the time reversal is actually
violating the k on decay
so there's fundamental and then you know
that they're bringing in cpt and usually
one says that the time reversal is
violated one day what one shows that cp
is violated and then one says that i got
a cpt theorem and therefore time
reverses knowledge but then their
argument was that well but cpd theorems
are completely depends on special
artistic local kind of field theories
and if you don't have specialized
quantum field theory then
you can't make such arguments so i told
those
it was quite um so that's an example
in which i think
younger people
making
understanding first of all what the
physics literature is saying and
understanding enough about unitarianity
and community operators what we need
what you don't need and such thing and
then making
a nice statement i think his name is
brian roberts and i think he's
they have already written a book he was
writing a book on this thing um
i just know because
the links to the philosopher and the
monk as well as brian roberts his work
or at least his google scholar page will
be in the description
thank you so much it's been quite a ride
more than four hours
okay
let's do this again at some point we'll
communicate over email and we'll see
also how this one goes online and see
what the reception is like
sounds very good okay
now
take care professor
okay
bye-bye bye
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full-time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you